Das war's für heute.
So, furious start.
Excellent, ex, genau wie es aussieht, Excellent.
oh vielleicht bisschen bis dezent ein bisschen zu groß eingestellt
du du du du exzellent so
so also vielleicht hat der ein oder andere im channel gekämpft oder so
ich wollte mir eigentlich auch medial an gucken ursprünglich aber dann ist mir aufgefallen ich
habe mir anfang des jahres schon open media volt angeguckt auf dem raspberry pi 4 und es hat mir
überhaupt nicht gefallen ich habe mich wieder dran erinnert und da habe ich mir gedacht wie
sieht es dann eigentlich mit freenas aus da bin ich bei freenas weil das habe ich gesagt ich habe
ja freenas eine weile verwendet allerdings hat mich das nicht so hundertprozentig überzeugt
für meine wohlgemerkt für meine anwendungszwecke ja ich sage nicht dass es schlecht ist aber für
meine anwendungszwecke weil an sich ist es gar nicht übel und da habe ich gedacht komm
guckst mal wieder bei freenas rein und da ist mir aufgefallen dass hier steht freenas will soon
be known as truna score und man kann es jetzt ausprobieren so habe ich mir gedacht das müssen
wir ausprobieren moin ja was jansky aber wenn man lesen kann das müssen wir ausprobieren
kann es jetzt runterladen wir probieren das entgegen das ist wahrscheinlich ein absoluter
frevel was wir hier machen wieder wir probieren es in der vm aus weil es einfach schneller
und einfacher geht und ich das hier nicht dauerhaft laufen lassen will zum testen ist es vor allem
am besten kann ich kann ich platten dran hängen wie ich will kommen rate ausprobieren können
wir zfs ausprobieren als mögliche wenn du das im also so eine sache die mir an freenas
persönlich nicht so gut gefallen hat war unabhängig vom produkt die community ging mir auf den
sack also ich war nie teil der community dass ich da im forum mich daran beteiligt hätte
oder so aber ich habe ab und zu mal wenn im forum so ein bisschen gelesen und ich hatte
das gefühl dass circa 90 prozent der leute im freenas forum absolute deppen sind die
eher leute abschrecken wollen das zu verwenden als ihnen zu helfen oder zumindest ihnen zu
sagen wo sie wo sie was ordentliches finden so dass also die community von freenas hat
mir nicht gefallen excellent song rutsche war hier finde ich rutsche da kannst du ja
was wir programmieren doch geht so warum ich meine ich kann mittlerweile sogar z plus
plus programmieren wenn man z plus plus programmieren kann kann man eigentlich fast
nahezu alles andere auch programmieren weil es schockt ein nichts mehr also wenn man wenn
man in z plus plus eine weile was gemacht hat alles andere selbst java script kann er nicht
mehr schocken selbst koboldig man ist man ist quasi ja man hat quasi 100 prozent lightning
resistance man kann nicht mehr geschockt werden von nichts wenn man sie ein bisschen z plus
plus gemacht hat brainfuck nein nix nix okay okay haskell vielleicht ja ja dann dann dann
versuchen wir jetzt mal kurz xxx mini finn i xxx zu helfen die x sind ganz essentiell
wahrscheinlich aber in zwischen können wir schon mal trunas runterladen ja schieß los
auf schicken in paste bin oder irgendwie sowas da können wir uns angucken also download also
moment bevor man das also ich kann ja nebenbei schon mal downloaden also ich hatte ja eine
weile frinas laufen auf dieser kiste hier hier habe ich jetzt auf gesagt die die fette
kiste die hatte die hatte frinas drauf unter anderem frinas da waren ja auch da waren ja
auch mehrere zehn terabyte platten drin und sowas so und das war nicht schlecht also ich
fand das an sich wirklich nicht übel unabhängig von diesem community aspekt wo ich den eindruck
hatte dass viele deppen unterwegs waren zum beispiel ist es auch so ein ding was du im frinas forum
wo die leute dann irgendwie voll voll so so so klühende verfechter dieser sache sind dass
die sagen du musst ecc speicher verwenden ich hatte ecc speicher drinne und du musst ich kriegst
aus dem kopf lieber zusammen mindestens ein gigabyte ram pro einem terabyte speicher haben und solche
geschichten also kriegst du kriegst du da in diesem forum erzählt das ist ja auch richtig oder so
ein richtwert wenn man das irgendwie high performance enterprise mäßig einsetzen will also ich glaube
kaum andere nasse oder oder distribution sei da so oft enterprise da drauf stehen wie frinas
aber trotzdem im heimbereich naja also im heimbereich muss jetzt muss also es läuft
ohne ecc ram genauso die tun ja fast schon so als geht es kaputt wenn du kein ecc ram verwendest
als würde es schlechter ohne ecc ram du merkst dann einige fehler nicht ohne ecc ram aber das
macht es auch nicht schlechter als jetzt sagen wir den xfs oder den ntfs oder den x4 oder so
no limit xo fünf monate dankeschön huge subscription wo habe ich wo habe ich nein falsche hier
dankeschön lass uns das morgen machen okay ob ich morgen da bin weiß ich nicht also wie
gesagt du musst mir mal schickt mir den paste bin dann kann ich dir vielleicht was zu sagen
so und das projekt scheint auch noch ziemlich aktiv zu sein weil es kam ja ein bisschen lauter
ne passt musik lautstärke müsste eigentlich ziemlich gut passend sein ich habe den zap von
eichler übersehen oje wusste eichler der eichler hat gesagt dreizehnte monat habe ich jetzt gar
gesehen das ist ja schon richtig aber richtig exquisite subscription der eichler was hat er
geschrieben 75 prozent aller was moment 75 prozent aller amerikanischen frauen tragen ein bh mit
für sie falscher kröse da kann doch jeder machen wie er will hast du das irgendwie von
1000 useless facts oder irgendwie solcher seite ja in die frage jetzt haben die meistens es zu
groß oder zu klein und wie ist das bei unterhosen von männern wäre auch noch interessant
das ist aber ich muss mal wieder den chat aufmachen das ist eine gute sache denn am wochenende
alter twitch warum vergisst du immer den dark mode am wochenende werden wir das hier ausprobieren
der liko hat gerade nämlich geschrieben er ist gerade mit seinem zynologie nass beschäftigt
am wochenende werden wir das hier ausprobieren ja ich kann sie richtig schreiben wenn wir das
hier ausprobieren und zwar sind da irgendwelche leute auf die idee gekommen musik kann man
ticken leiser machen oder so und zwar sind da leute auf die idee gekommen und haben das
zynologie betriebssystem genommen also die nintendo songs sind mir heute ein wenig zu
energie geladen auch wenn es die pokemon fans wieder absolut geschockt sind ich glaube ich
brauche doch irgendwas irgendwas entspannenderes klein gibt sie mario galaxy aber relaxing mario
galaxy musik gibt es bestimmt playlist exquisite
ja das lassen wir das ist pepo pepo happy blanket die mario galaxy musik
gut wo bin ich stehen geblieben genau es gibt irgendwelche leute die haben das zynologie
betriebssystem genommen und haben das extrahiert und so gebaut dass man es sich selbst installieren
kann und das probieren wir das probieren wir auch noch einmal aus ich habe keine ahnung
ob das was taugt ehrlich gesagt und das werden wir übrigens auch auf echter hardware ausprobieren
ich weiß mal gucken was auch die was die recommended hardware ist ja davon habe ich ne davon habe
ich moment ne davon habe ich noch welche da und zwar probieren wir das auf einer low
power intel plattform aus ich habe hier noch drei mainboards einfach so weil die hatte
ich mal irgendwann gekauft die kommen jetzt mal für was sinnvolles verwenden das probieren
wir mal am wochenende aus wie gesagt ich habe keine ahnung ob es was taugt das müssen wir
mal gucken serious max sagt taucht nix ja müssen wir mal schauen zumindest probieren
jetzt mal eine runde truenas aus was denn das wohl der nachfolger von oder das wird wohl
der nachfolger von frinas und es soll wohl weggehen von freebsd auf irgendeinen linux
wenn ich das richtig gesehen habe oder das stand doch hier irgendwo demian ja kann sein
so download probieren wir mal aus exellent was einloggen zum downloaden ah ne jebaited
warum soll ich mir so kacke newsletter eintragen ja die immer mit dem newsletter zeichnen
no take me to downloads ah yes oh habt ihr gesehen wie der download button einfadet wenn
man die seite lädt hoho da wollen sie es aber wissen ihr schaut euch das mal an guck
mal hier seite lädt und jetzt auf was mit der seite los bin ich jetzt schon bin ich
jetzt schon ip blocked weil ich weil ich zweimal refreshed habe es gibt truenas scale auf
demian aha wo gibt es das zum herunterladen ok wir gucken uns jetzt nicht an wie das einfadet
ok der download ist aber wenigstens schnell easykiller 12 monate exquisite scale funktioniert
noch nicht so gut truenas scale download wir können das auch noch mal ausprobieren was
truenas moment das hat mich doch hier gerade ah ne das ist truenas core aha das ist truenas
core ok dann bleibt das auf freebsd und das hier ist wahrscheinlich dann so in zukunft
das für linux geschichten ja ja das das kriegen wir schon ich seh early development
download wir können sie mal runterladen vielleicht können wir sie später noch angucken mal schauen
proxy ops ja da sind sie gerade bei uns auf der arbeit die sind ja gerade schwer im alles
alles muss nach azure modus und jetzt fällt ihnen bei manchen systemen auf dass es halt
gar nicht so einfach ist die sinnvoll in azure zu bringen weil also sachen in die cloud umziehen
heißt ja nicht unbedingt dass man einfach den server nimmt den man hat ein image zieht
und in azure in der vm steckt das machen wir aber gerade weil die leute gar keinen bock
haben das richtig umzuziehen aber so macht man es also das ist how to wie man nicht in
die cloud mit kreiert aber ist mir alles mittlerweile wurscht die sollen machen was sie was sie
die sollen die sollen machen was sie wollen es interessiert mich nicht so lange die mein
gehalt pünktlich bezahlt es wird alles egal weil ich sag es ja immer im stream man arbeitet
nicht um zu leben man leben sein schwachsinn man lebt nicht um zu arbeiten man lebt nicht
um zu arbeiten man arbeitet um zu leben so also sollen sie machen was sie wollen mir scheiß
egal ob es das überlau überweisen das gehalt pünktlich kannst du ein store schreck mit
mindestens acht bei empfehlen wie gesagt ich habe da gerade ja auch im heimbereich nicht
wirklich viel ausprobiert ich habe da meine 4 e-kiste mal zusammengeschustert und bin
danach nachdem ich das ein jahr oder zwei jahre verwendet habe drauf gekommen dass
eigentlich maßlos auf was da ist war jemand erfahrung mit selbstgebautem das ja ich habe
im prinzip seit jahre nur selbst selbst gebaute nasse allerdings ich baue ja nie wirklich
an sich denn dass ich hab da meistens eine kiste die halt auch noch ein bisschen pfeilsaber
mitmacht so da legen wir das mal an also du wirst schon mal wobei wir können wir können
die 4m hier recyceln die haben wir doch schon immer der 130 g 8 g memory machen wir mal
ein bisschen mehr komm 8 g da gibt sich free nas nicht damit zufrieden wir brauchen 16
g ach nee das geht ja hier in ja 20 mb ist klar 16 16 g aber ich hab keine ahnung was
exakte 16 g ist so also wir machen hier eine disk rein passt gut wir installieren das erst
und danach hängen wir noch ein paar disks dazu und gucken ob der alles erkennt und so
was und schauen uns an ob das ob das tut iso freena scale trunas 12 ach guck mal die behalten
auch die versionsnummer freenas war nämlich bei 11 und trunas ist jetzt bei 12 ok schauen
wir uns das ganze mal an bei der gelegenheit hallo oh nein es hängt wieder bei der gelegenheit
da können wir deep in klein mal löschen zack hallo warum leckt denn das so rum gibt's noch
false nas pains champ false nas freenas war glaube ich schon mal ich bin mir bei freenas
nicht so sicher ich weiß nicht ob es version 13 war die hatten mal nen größeren streit
dort da haben die neue freenas version rausgebracht und dann ist irgendwie noch der gründer abgehauen
und so was oder und haben sich übelst gezofft und nachdem der typ weg war wurde es dann
wieder wieder zurückgerollt und so was die hatten der übel stress ich weiß nicht ob
das 11 oder 12 oder 13 war ist trunas jetzt ein fork von freenas nee so wie es aussieht
ist trunas der nachfolger von freenas also freenas elf wird so trunas zwölf
chat sagt überlege mir gerade machen wir kurz hier unten weg
hier überlege mir gerade ein mini etx nas mit zwei festplatten sowieso welche software
da empfehlt wird also meine bisherige wie soll man sagen nas nas weg sieht folgendermaßen
aus ich hatte mal was war denn das also ich habe mal irgendwann angefangen mit diesem
ganzen selbst bastel kram mit ihrem adlon xp fragt mich nicht 1800 sonst was da man damals
hatte ich das total loop style ohne jegliche ahnung habe ich den windows drauf installiert
und habe einfach nen ordner freigegeben und hat mir gedacht alter bin ich geil ich hab
jetzt ein super krasses nas gebaut ich glaube das kennt jeder jeder hat mal irgendwie so
angefangen irgendwie will was drauf geklatscht so und danach bin ich auf die glorreiche idee
gekommen ich nehme meinen alten gaming rechner wie gesagt wir reden hier irgendwie von frag
mich nicht 2004 5 oder so aber kam aber hat moment ich bin im falschen adlon xp wann gab
es denn die jaja das ist so alt ok so und irgendwann bin ich auf die glorreiche idee
gekommen da habe ich voll verschissen meinen alten gaming rechner zu nehmen für den nas
beziehungsweise für für falls aber das ist ganz ehrlich in der regel ist damit eigentlich
mehr oder weniger falls aber halt klar man macht damit noch mehr aber so unter das was
man eigentlich hauptsächlich verwenden ist die falls aber komponente davon so und da
bin ich auf die glorreiche idee gekommen max nimmst deinen gaming rechner und machst
daraus machst wieder update ist das und habe ich wieder windows installiert und habe damals
auch wieder ordner freigegeben und ich habe es da richtig verschissen ich hatte damals
nämlich nen chipsatz nvd ja endlich ist es nforce 2 oder so ja genau irgendwie so ne
innen war das für amnedes für k7 da war es bestimmt nforce 4 oder nforce 3 es ist auch
vollkommen egal welches das war zumindest war das nen war das nen nvd sockel 939 klink
klingt relativ passend ja zumindest hatte ich da so nen so nen mainboard mit nvd chipsatz
damals hat nvd ja noch mainboards chipsetze gemacht und so was machen die ja mittlerweile
nicht mehr zumindest habe ich schon ewig keinen mehr gesehen so und das hatte damals nen
eingebautes so so bios rate software rate eingebaut und ich habe gedacht max du bist
jetzt super big brain und klatscht da einfach alle festplatten rein die so hast das waren
damals frag mich nicht irgendwie 250 g festplatten oder sowas also es war nicht viel so und dann
bin ich auf die glorreiche idee gekommen und raset mal was ich gemacht habe erst mal nvd
ja software rate 0 so und da fand ich mich natürlich total geil ne moment nicht 250
g festplatten 80 oder 70 g festplatten ich glaube 70 was war aber festplatten 70 oder
80 g 70 g oder waren es 80 g festplatten oder 140 g 80 ne dann waren es 2 mal das stimmt
überhaupt nicht 250 ich hab 2 mal 80 und ich bilde mir sogar ein das waren so ultra schnelle
mit mit mit 10 ja sowas hier so ich bin mir nicht sicher ob sie aber sowas in der richtung
war das wie gesagt das war mein alter gaming rechner und ich habe damals ultra die performance
hdds gehabt so irgendwas sowas war das war auf jeden fall total bescheuert so dann habe
ich damals zwei stück 2 stück habe ich damals rate 0 gemacht ich wollte aussehen sagen
rate 1 aber es war rate 0 ihr könnt euch ihr könnt euch vorstellen wie gut das funktioniert
hat an sich ist gegen rate 0 ja gar nichts zu sagen wenn man weiß worauf man sich einlässt
und irgendwo war es mir klar also ich wusste damals schon dass in rate 0 keine allzu gute
idee ist aber ich habe mir gedacht ich habe also zwei krasse high end ich habe damals
halt gedacht es werden die ultra krassen high end platten schlechthin ja und da habe ich
das halt zusammengebaut und es ist auch nie das rate kaputt gegangen aber dieser das war
dann also das mainboard und das mainboard das ist das ist so ein fehler das ist so unglaublich
bescheuert dass das muss man erst mal haben dass man weiß worauf man achten muss das
mainboard hat einen aktiven kühler drauf gehabt sowas hier also so ein ding das hat
einen aktiven alter ist das hässlich ne ne das war zumindest hat das mainboard einen
aktiven kühler drauf gehabt und der aktive kühler ist verreckt ohne das was mitbekommen
hat und dann hat sich im laufenden betrieb das rate selber kaputt geschrieben weil der
chipsatz überhitzt ist und das hat man erst gemerkt nach dem neustart und nach dem neustart
ging das ganze ding nicht mehr so das war so mein das war so meine meine erste richtige
selbstbau nass erfahrung ja das heißt ich habe gleich ich habe gleich gelernt wie was
wie was nicht macht aber das war echt ein fieser fehler dass da irgendwie der chipsatz
überhitzt der auch fürs rate zuständig ist und das rate sich dann kaputt schreibt war
ganz merkwürdig ich hätte es aber eigentlich schon merken können ich hätte schon merken
können weil die kiste ist immer mal wieder hängen geblieben und wenn du die nicht also
als es noch mal ein gaming rechner war wohlgemerkt als ich es noch nicht zum nass umgebaut habe
als es noch mal ein gaming rechner war und ich musste die kiste die ist hängen geblieben
halt eben weil das mainboard überhitzt ist vermute ich mal ich habe es halt nicht ich
hätte damals mal reingucken sollen übrigens damals hatte ich auch so einen geilen falls
ich noch eine an die zahlmann zahle hier so ein lüfter hatte ich damals hier exquisite
zahlmann kühler weiß gar nicht ob die überhaupt noch sachen machen die fand die waren die
waren richtig premium damals zumindest ich musste da mein gaming rechner wenn er hängen
geblieben ist musste ich den total schnell resetten weil das mainboard sonst halt auch
die festplatte weil das halt überhitzt war ich kann ich kann es mir bis heute nicht genau
erklären zumindest als die festplatte kaputt geschrieben das heißt dass das das war dann
ungefähr so spielen spielen spielen auch rechner hängt rechner hängt reset ganz
schnell ganz schnell runter ans gehäuse springen und reset schalter drücken weil wenn ich
den reset schalter nicht in drei vier sekunden geschrieben habe konnte sein dass die windows
installation kaputt ist also mit so nem kack hat man sich damals rumgeschlagen ja wie oft
ich windows check das gesehen habe damals totaler müll gut wie bin ich jetzt wie bin
ich jetzt überhaupt drauf gekommen auf die ganze sache sehr gut sehr gut ok keine ahnung
ich weiß ich weiß immer wie ich drauf wie ich das wie ich da drauf gekommen bin zumindest
die letzten jahre habe ich mir dann gedacht ok max übertreibst man nicht bau dir mal
was ordentliches und dann habe ich mir halt diese 4h e-kiste zusammengebaut mit den mit
den 10 terabyte platten trenner und die lief auch wunderbar aber das war halt total auf
was heißt und jetzt habe ich das billigste nass aller Zeiten also dass das ist das das
easyste billigste nass aller Zeiten ich habe hier so eine low power intel kiste stehen neben
mir die nicht nur nass macht da läuft auch noch ein wiki drauf und das heim automatisierung
zeug läuft da auch noch drauf und da ist einfach eine 12 terabyte platte dran und nen
samba server drauf installiert fertig da ist ne bunte server drauf mit allem anderen da
hängt ne 10 terabyte platte dran samba drauf fertig das ist mein nass ohne ich mach da
gar keine großartigen faxen mehr und da gibt es noch ne usb platte auf die er singt wird
nachts fertig das ist alles also ich bin wirklich von abenteuerlichem selbst bastel kram über
maßlos überdimensioniertes heimserver zeug zu der billigsten nasslosung aller Zeiten
gekommen und damit bin ich ehrlich gesagt zufrieden das funktioniert wunderbar boot
from cd rom ok es ist es ist noch es ist noch freebsd android habe ich noch nie ausprobiert
ich kenne ich kenne das aber ich habe mir bisher nie ich wollte bisher nie quasi android
als betriebssystem drauf haben weil ich lieber ein vollständiges linux habe wo ich alles
drauf machen kann ich weiß nicht ob man nen android oder auf was android basiert keine
ahnung samba 4 als windows ad alternativ war meine abschlussarbeit excellent proxmox habe
ich auch ausprobiert das ist alles ganz nice aber ich bin mittlerweile so auf dem stand
dass ich dass ich die meisten sachen am liebsten einfach selbst mache halt mögt so einfach
wie es irgendwie geht dass man sich nie wieder großartig drum kümmern muss und eine sache
die ich auch festgestellt habe so die letzten jahre es ist besser man macht es einfacher
also gerade im heimbereich man macht die sachen möglichst einfach anstatt dass wirklich so
das letzte das letzte vizelchen ab abgefackelt wird von dem was man sich vielleicht noch
ausdenken kann und das allerwichtigste ist dass man sich selbst nen paar man muss sich
nicht viel aufschreiben aber so ein paar sätze zu den einzelnen systemen die man selbst
insgesamt aufschreibt ja zum beispiel das ist was weiß ich die kiste ist dafür da let's
encrypt zertifikat abzurufen deswegen muss das alles in diesem in diesem ordner liegen
und wenn das zertifikat abläuft und nicht erneuert wird dann hängt es wahrscheinlich
daran irgendwie sowas reicht schon voll und ganz aber ich habe schon so oft meine eigenen
systeme die backt weil ich nach einem halben jahr oder zwei jahren oder sonst was wo es
nicht mal funktioniert hat nicht mehr wusste was ich da selbst gebaut habe dass ich mittlerweile
angefangen habe mir zu jedem system so ein bisschen was aufzuschreiben und das hat sich
echt gelohnt spätestens wenn man sich fragt welche festplatte an welchem anschluss ist
und und sowas oder welche festplatte oder welche seriennummer welche festplatte hat
die gerade ausgefallen ist und solche dinger so also wenn man install exzellent kommt davon
wenn man alles keck weh nennt ich nenne ich alles keck weh also meine internen kisten
die heißen glaube ich gerade a ja ja lul weh poggers weiß ich aus dem kopf gar nicht
alles dumme dumme twitch twitch emote heißen internen kisten bei mir gerade aber die meine
internen kisten sind tatsächlich so benannt dass man nicht unbedingt auf den zweck schließen
kann deswegen ist es auch gerade wichtig dass man sich was aufschreibt allerdings dafür
habe ich meine domain namen halbwegs sinnvoll gemacht weil sowas kann man sich merken und
ob die kiste unten drunter jetzt poggers heißt beziehungsweise dass der container poggers
heißt ist ja vollkommen wurscht so habe ich ja schon mal erzählt wie gut meine heizungsüberwachung
funktioniert bates jam ja ich habe ein doku wiki ich habe auch mehrere wiki software durchprobiert
und doku wiki ist nach wie vor das einfachste und beste finde ich so this will erase all
partitions and data yes password a 123456 hast du ein confluence zu hause ne wird du
im leben nicht installieren confluence ist so im enterprise umfeld gar nicht mal so übel
wir haben es ja auch auf der arbeit das problem an confluence für mich im im im wobei stimmt
eigentlich gar nicht das problem für mich im allgemeinen an confluence ist dass das
alles in irgendet so einem obskuren xml format in der datenbank speichert das gute an doku
wiki ist dass das plaintext ohne jegliche datenbank den ganzen mist auf dem filesystem
speichert hast du schon mal ugo ja ja habe ich das ist aber eher so eine blogging geschichte
also würde ich jetzt was boot via bios bios moment ich war eben das habe ich noch eingestellt
habe ich ihn eingestellt bios ich bin ich bin jetzt mal kurz um rename trunas what rename
trunas warum durfte ich es eben nicht umbenennen nico zuerst neun monate excellent dankeschön
für den sub huge subscription kannst du mal zeigen wie man doku wiki konfiguriert ja ich
habe folgendes gemacht weil ich gar keinen bock hatte mich damit zu beschäftigen ja ich
glaube das da habe ich das da ich glaube ich hatte am anfang das da den container und
hab dann den genommen weil der irgendwann mal irgendwelche berechtigungsprobleme hatte
ich weiß auch nicht was aber ich glaube ich habe jetzt den und damit ist halt easy einfach
starten und gutes aber eine sache ist wichtig gucken wir mal hier kurz in der konfig eine
sache ist wichtig du musst halt hier die die volumes angeben dass das persistent ist also
muss das muss sagen wo er die sache die seiten ablegt das war es aber mehr musst du nicht
machen und ein ein eine wichtige sache wenn man doku wiki im container laufen lässt beziehungsweise
wenn man doku doku wiki im sagen wir jetzt irgendwie mit einem docker compose laufen
lässt und im hintergrund die container aktualisieren lässt dann sollte man unbedingt eine version
hardcoded reinschreiben weil doku wiki hat den die angewohnheit wenn man das hier auf
latest stehen lässt also man sollte sich irgendwas raussuchen in irgendwas was festes was sich
nicht ändert weil wenn es auf latest stehen lässt geht es nach einem jahr kaputt weil
die irgendwelche breaking changes gemacht haben und das einfach im hintergrund aktualisiert
also schreibt eine feste versionsnummer ein und gut und gut ist ja also ich habe bei mir
keine container bis auf den hallo weltcontainer habe ich nirgendswo latest drin stehen was
ich bei containern immer mache ist ich schreibe die sofern dass die das anbieten schreibe
ich immer die letzte version rein inclusive ward fixes also dass ich dann beispielsweise
wenn man nextcloud nimmt schreibt man nicht rein nextcloud latest sondern ich zeige euch
mal was ich meine bevor ich jetzt hier lang rum laber dann schreibt man nicht drauf nextcloud
latest sondern schreibt zum beispiel stable ist aber auch schwierig man sollte die versionsnummer
komplett reinschreiben ja man schreibt dann zum beispiel 2019 rein so und viele container
bieten so was an dass man 19 reinschreiben kann so was wie das hier das ist dann immer
die neueste 19er version mit den neuesten hotfixes allerdings update ist nie von sich
aus auf 20 und das würde ich auch gerade bei so sachen wie nextcloud und doku wiege immer
so machen weil die gehen auch mal ganz gerne kaputt bei einem upgrade also latest ist meistens
keine allzu gute idee ist auch ein ist auch ein ding wo ich finde das wird in so docker
und und generell container tutorials ein bisschen vernachlässigt die so ein container tutorial
geht immer so rum so nach dem motto oh it's so easy so easy neue container zack zack guck
mal hier so easy 15 neue container gespawnt und alles funktioniert zusammen nicht mehr
geil aber in zwei wochen ist kaputt und da geht da geht kaum einer drauf ein also es
ist ja schön und gut wenn man so easy 15 container spawnen kann aber wenn es was ist was ich
eine weile laufen lassen muss muss ich mir da genauso wie bei allem anderen auch gedanken
drüber machen dass es nicht kaputt geht und übrigens nextcloud sage ich ja schon ein
halbes jahr fliegt bei mir wieder raus ich habe einfach kein großartiges verwendungszweck
für weil die ganze nextcloud also das was nextcloud ausmacht diese ganzen plugins zum
größten teil einfach nur halbherzig umgesetzt sind ich meine die suche geht nicht und die
suche in notizen geht nicht richtig das ist ja schon mal der witz das nur eine eine sache
wir haben es ja letztens im stream angeguckt das war einfach alles total unfertig so 16
gigabyte swap ja mein wegen wir haben genug platz nextcloud ist absoluter trash patrick
ich gebe dir mittlerweile echt es gibt total viele verfechter von von nextcloud aber nextcloud
ist an vielen stellen einfach absolut unfertig und also nextcloud besteht so aus der mischung
aus total unfertigen anwendung und total unpolished anwendung und es gibt so ein paar sachen die
sind ganz gut aber das meiste ist unfertig absolut unpolished oder schlicht und ergreifend
kaputt das hat müll so was ganz was ganz gut funktioniert ist halt so die diese basic
calda auf karta auf geschichte aber dafür brauche ich kein volles nextcloud dafür kann
ich irgendwas kleines fertiges nehmen so gut collaboration features test probiere ich nicht
aus zur collaboration kann ich nichts sagen ich weiß nur die eingebauten apps mit notizen
zum beispiel funktioniert die suche nicht richtig aber wir haben es wir haben es letztens
im schrieben ausbild alles total unfertig hier könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern dieses
kann man bord wo man nicht richtig treten und kopp treten und trocken konnte drin richtig
richtig kaputt ja aber auch die offiziellen plugins sind müll wie gesagt das notizen
plugin kann keine notizen richtig durchsuchen oder was es tut es kann auch sein dass es
das to do plugin war ich bin mir nicht mal ganz ich glaube das war das notizen plugin
was keine notizen richtig durchsuchen konnte und solche dinge so reboot system excellent
ich weiß was brauche ich denn eine notiz app im browser die notizen nicht durchsuchen
kann durchsuchen ist 95 prozent was man in den notizen macht oder sind eure notizen
nur right only ihr schreibt nur notizen liest nie drin was er ziemlich sinnlos ist sich
dafür notizen zu machen ja evernote finde ich auch gut one note finde ich auch nicht
schlecht allerdings ich will nix gehostetes verwenden nicht ist wie gesagt ich würde
am liebsten als eigenes verwenden und da bin ich mittlerweile bei bei dings hier hängen
geblieben die können nicht so viel wie next cloud die mobile vor allem die android app
ist ein bisschen merkwürdig ich kann es nicht anders umschreiben dass du teilweise
erst dass dass du nicht in den notizen reinklicken kannst sondern erst auf den icon klicken
musst zum edit hier und so aber ok da kann ich über alles hinweg sehen und die haben
den web klipper wo man web content klippen kann also ich sag mal 95 prozent der sachen
die ich machen will vor allem weil es cross platform ist wird davon ganz gut abgefackelt
ja der kraft der grafische editor den brauche ich nicht ich schreibe hier nur markdown und
ich schreibe auch nur markdown exquisite musik ja und ich schreibe auch nur markdown mit
dem sündagshighlighting wegen ich mache keinen markdown preview an also ich benutze markdown
eigentlich nur zum sündagshighlighting strukturieren und dass man es ab und zu mal als html rendern
kann wenn man will genau web in der phase 2 alles klar komm wir starten mal die ledungskiste
warum soll man das von windows aus machen lull was ist markdown markdown and wir brauchen
ein markdown stream glaub da kann man nicht allzu viel zeigen so ich zeig dir mal mal
gucken ob es einen guten online markdown editor gibt der ist ganz ok markdown ist ne ja wenn
ich jetzt sage markup das ist eigentlich bescheuert du kannst mit markdown plaintext ein bisschen
hübscher formatieren stimmt einfach wishlist studio code aufmachen ja stimmt man kommt
da in eine neue haustour ja wie gesagt ich versuche ja die ganze zeit schon wir machen
mal kurz ich versuche die ganze zeit schon irgendwas zu überlegen wie ich meine home
automation tour machen kann so also jetzt haben wir eine markdown datei auf und du kannst
jetzt eigentlich ziemlich eins zu eins den text schreiben den du sonst schreiben willst
also sowas wie hier keine ahnung notiz notes einkaufen keckw ne wir machen chat spammen
keckw omega lull lullw ne moment ist es minus oder ich glaube es ist minus so also im prinzip
kannst du markdown mehr oder weniger 1 zu 1 zu schreiben wie du plaintext schreibst aber
der vorteil davon ist erstens dass du ein bisschen syntax highlighting zum strukturieren
bekommst ja du kannst auch text fett machen und sowas aber das praktische ist musst du
die mal ausdrucken oder musst du die mal ein bisschen hübsch machen deine notizen dann
ist es relativ einfach weil markdown kannst du gleichermaßen total easy zu html umwandeln
weißt du ob das stand markdown preview hier drin so du kriegst markdown dran relativ hübsch
gerendert wenn du es denn mal brauchst aber wie gesagt diese vorschau verwende ich eigentlich
so gut wie gar nicht ich schreibe eigentlich markdown nur als plaintext du kannst da beispielsweise
auch source code schnipsel rein machen zum beispiel irgendwie ruby so dann hat er sogar
syntax highlighting each ne moment ruby ruby oh fuck lang kein ruby mehr gemacht irgendwie
so glaube so kannst du hast quasi auch ein bisschen syntax du hast syntax highlighting
für source code ach das ist bold text siehst du so spezielle sachen verwende ich gar nicht
okay das ist dick pepo fett text max in zwei wochen film die kottbete statt bist du dabei
ich werde es mir mal angucken ich werde wahrscheinlich ausrasten nach drei runden dank skill based
schmecken uns nicht mehr anfassen aber ich guck es mir an also angucken wir jetzt auf
jeden fall wie gesagt ich fürchte ich werde sich lang durchhalten so es gibt noch zig
erweiterungen es gibt zum beispiel erweiterungen dass man matte geschichten ordentlich darstellen
kann und dass man latech geschichten schreiben kann und so was aber ach so man kann übrigens
auch tabellen machen wenn ich das jetzt aus dem kopf hinkriege lull moment moment markdown
tabellen aus ach du scheiße wie ging markdown tabellen aus dem kopf und wie ich ich kann
mir immer nicht merken wie tabellen funktionieren da gibt es aber auch plugins die machen für
dich einfach die tabellen markdown table generator exquisite so ach so was genau guck der macht
den dann auch eine halbwegs hübsche halbwegs hübsche html tabelle und solche geschichten
draus ist nice also lohnt sich ein bisschen zu lernen gibt es nicht viel zu lernen das
war ich schon mehr oder weniger alles ja so und so kannst du deinen text ein bisschen
besser strukturieren und wenn du es mal in schön brauchst zum ausdrucken kannst du einfach
html draus machen so eins und zwei einserkel 2.141 war es ah jetzt trunas so ähm was
hatten wir hier admin 123456 ach nee moment was admin oder was root root 123456 ok also
standardmäßig dark theme das finde ich schon mal äußerst praktisch also ihr seht es ist
nicht es ist nicht mein dark reader das ist halt wirklich standardmäßig dark theme und
das finde ich schon mal ganz gut i low 1706 sieben monate exquisite subscription excellent
und jetzt ist gar kein prime subscriber ist ein richtig echter stonks hier gehen ruff
so ähm so ich hatte frina schon ganz lange nicht mehr installiert jetzt gucken wir uns
das mal an kann man dann kann man dann hell machen wenn man hell machen will i a dark
theme blu deutsche sonnenbrille ich hoffe jetzt keiner vom rechner zerschütz geschmolzen
oder so drakula also sie ein bisschen aus wie das default intelli j und und rider sieben
also ist ja immer ihr wisst ja immer das wichtigste erstmal die oberflächen themes angucken die
das ist ein bisschen material design hier würde ich sagen so auch von den man kann immer ganz
gut testen ob eine webseite oder eine app material design mäßig sein will wenn man
einen knopf gedrückt hält und dass diese diese knopf drück animation abspielt das
ist so typische material design geschichte und wenn es das macht versuchen sie zumindest
material sein design zu sein so high contrast ok das ist einfach hell er sieht er sieht
aber schon mal muss ich ehrlich sagen es sieht schon mal besser aus ich ich mache es jetzt
mal hell weil ich das gefühl habe das helle theme ist ein bisschen besser gemacht es sieht
schon mal um 300 prozent besser aus als das alte frinas was ich hatte was war das frinas
9 frinas 8 vielleicht sogar ne frinas 9 war das glaube ich was ich auf der kiste hatte
ja das das sah umständlicher aus auf jeden fall kann ich mich doch dunkel dran erinnern
du musst den server umziehen ja brauchst du kohle oder wie oder was soll ich den server
bezahlen ich meine ist ja immerhin das zeug von mir drauf ja also du hast open media volt
hat mir absolut nicht gefallen wir haben ja ich hab dann den stream zugemacht und ich
bin überhaupt nicht warm geworden mit vor allem weil man laufend irgendwelche dinger
bestätigen musste unsinnigerweise und dann gar nicht mal richtig rollbacken können ganz
merkwürdig das ist das einzige was bei mir hängen geblieben ist dass man jeden klick
bestätigen musste ob es jetzt irgendwas war was gespeichert werden musste oder nicht
man musste alles irgendwie doppelt und dreifach bestätigen man musste safen noch mal safen
und dann bestätigen und sowas das war ganz merkwürdig in open media volt ja sehbar zieh
ruhig um also sprich da nichts dagegen also wenn du irgendwie da bisschen bisschen kohle
brauchst für den sauberen kann sag bescheid so also was können wir denn jetzt hier schönes
machen ich muss mir erstmal ein bisschen hier übersicht was ist das da oben task manager
ok da kann ich sehen wenn was hängt oder sowas progress 100% ach nee das ist paket
updates oder was ist das nee was ist das was soll uns was soll uns der progress da hinten
sagen ach nee das ist wenn ich was applye wann das fertig ist ah verstehe ok also wenn
ich irgendwas ändere was ein bisschen dauert dann sehe ich hier wie weit er ist so alerts
gibt es nicht settings haben wir uns schon angeguckt gibt es nicht das retro logo excellent
ok also dashboard es sieht viel viel hübscher aus auf jeden fall schon mal als das alte sieht
man vielleicht auch auf welcher basis das ganze ist e polifilm material design icons prime
icons styles nee ich mein welches css gedöns das ist was ist denn das q ql container ah
ql container was salesforce hier das ist der editor moment das ist der editor ok keine
ahnung wahrscheinlich haben sie das css selbst gemacht ist jetzt auch nett also das würde
ich auch noch halbwegs gebacken kriegen so eine karte zu machen so also man sieht wie
viel speicher man sieht wie viel frei ist hier wir müssen gleich festplatten dran
hängen dass man das dass man was ordentlich machen können damit man kann account seinrichten
auch klar hier gibt es aber jede menge zeug mal schauen dass die musik nicht so laut ist
ne passt ande acht monate dankeschön exquisite subscription ich freestyler nur klar umsocht
in deutschland so ntp so was kann man eintragen ja guck mal wird sogar dynamisch nachgeladen
hier sonst wird es wahrscheinlich leggen wenn ich die seite wechsle weil das ist ein
bisschen schneller gehen könnte beim zweitmal anklicken ok general settings ist für uns
jetzt erst mal relativ uninteressant hatte dps redirect juckt mich jetzt nicht dps aber
gut was kann man da auswählen default ok vielleicht kann man dort bei einem update
unterschiedliche sachen booten also sprich wenn das update fehlt schlägt kann ich ins
alte system wieder booten oder sowas in 2020 nicht schlecht ne ne das ist das ist definitiv
kein bootstrap hier das sieht überhaupt nicht bootstrap mäßig aus ok nix interessantes
email ok man kann es benachrichtigen lassen vielleicht bei irgendwelchen sachen auch nicht
so interessant system data set gut das ok es ist immer noch standardmäßig zfs das sieht
man schon mal an den namen von den dingern irgendwelche stonks stonks crafts kann man
generieren soll uns jetzt auch mal egal sein man kann sich benachrichtigen lassen wenn
was ist cloud credentials ne ssh connection brauchen wir jetzt auch nicht tunables ok
update gucken ob es updates gibt ca certifikate autentifizierungs stelle to factor autentifizierung
ist dabei das finde ich gut das finde ich schon mal cool dass das stamm ich zwei faktor
autentifizierung dabei ist das immer nice ich ich finde alles gut was mittlerweile default
mäßig zu faktor autentifizierung mitbringt also in einheit nicht alle ich finde nicht
also ich finde es immer gut wenn was heute standardmäßig zwei faktor autentifizierung
mitbringt auch wenn ich bei den meisten internen sachen ich habe aber ich finde es gut wenn
es standardmäßig mitbringt da weiß ich mich dass es maintained ist und nicht über
irgendwelche sich tritt party plugins die dann ab und zu kaputt gehen man sich nicht
mal einloggen kann sich das besorgen muss ok con shops kann man anlegen in den shutdowns
clips erste er ok das ist praktisch ich glaube das ging bei der sache die ich verwendet hab
noch nicht da könnte ich jetzt zum beispiel sagen ok ich mache eine usb festplatte dran
und sync einmal nachts das ist sehr praktisch snapshot task das ist für zfs wir machen
gleich wir machen gleich mal einen zfs rate 1 mit zwei test festplatten man kann das
ist auch praktisch dass man automatisch snapshots anlegen kann also bei zfs ist es so dass snapshots
keinen speicher verbrauchen erst wenn sich was ändert verbrauchen snapshots speichern
also es gibt ja so zwei ansätze wenn man snapshots macht entweder gruppiert man den
aktuellen stand wo man also man sagt ich mache jetzt einen snapshot von dem inhalt
dieser dieser sagen wir mal platte oder dieses verzeichnis dies data pool oder wie immer
man das jetzt genau nennen macht ich mache jetzt ein snapshot und da wie gesagt gibt
es zwei varianten entweder ich kopiere einfach alles dann ändert sich danach nichts mehr
dran aber es belegt immer fett platz oder man macht die zfs variante man link das quasi
einfach nur um und speicher dann das diff dazu das hat den vorteil am anfang braucht
das snapshot überhaupt nichts zusätzlich an speicher aber umso größer und im und
umso unterschiedlicher sich beides voneinander entwickelt umso größer wird das ganze ja
also ja und snapshots sind natürlich ultra schnell da der schöne daran ist wenn man
so snapshots quasi so mit umlinken macht und deltas speichern und diff speichern wenn
es nur snapshots sind die man kurz macht dann geht es schnell und braucht kein speicher
wenn man jetzt allerdings snapshots ein halbes jahr oder jahr liegen lassen will gegen
den datenbestand der sich viel und schnell und oft und auch bandbreiten mäßig viel
schnell ändert dann ist es vielleicht nicht so die beste variante aber zumindest kann
man hier periodisch snapshots anlegen was beispielsweise bei einem fileserver gar nicht
so übel ist überlegt euch mal mal ihr baut jetzt das super krasse enterprise nass für
irgend so nem kann für eine werbe agentur oder so oder oder noch besser noch besser
für die stonks personalabteilung und die speichern da irgendwelche excel-listen drauf so und
irgendeine kommt auf die idee wir löschen jetzt einfach mal irgendwie fünf excel-files
weil sie denkt sie ist auf ihrem desktop und oder einer ja muss man ja aufpassen was man
sagt und dann habt ihr den vorteil wenn ihr immer wieder regelmäßig snapshots macht
können sagen ok die arbeit ist alle noch da ich mache einfach rollback von vor zwei
stunden snapshots passt und dadurch dass snapshots diese art von zfs snapshots mehr oder weniger
fast umsonst sind wenn sie kurzlebig sind könnt ihr es euch und auch schnell gehen
könnt ihr es euch theoretisch ohne probleme leisten da keine ahnung jede halbe stunde
stunde den snapshots zu machen und die halt so zu rotieren dass sie nicht allzu alt werden
eigentlich eigentlich eine coole sache dass man das hier automatisch machen kann also
sprich wenn man angst hat dass sie ihr eigenes zeug löschen einfach snapshots machen lassen
und relativ schnell rotieren und gut ist was würdest du denn als fileserver am besten
einbauen was moment nfs samba oder ihr seht das ist beides also die ersten zwei kamen
auch vergleichen das letzte nicht so wirklich also sowohl nfs als auch samba nfs würde
ich schon mal nicht machen weil ich hauptsächlich windows also nicht hauptsächlich aber viele
windows clients hab so also das fällt schon mal flach man kann zwar nfs irgendwie unter
windows zum laufen kriegen aber war drauf geschissen so deswegen würde ich eigentlich
immer samba nehmen und ist ist was ganz anderes weil die beiden sind schert also sprich das
ist auf also quasi auf anwendungs logik ebene gibt das einen ordner frei wo mehrere benutzer
gleichzeitig drauf können gleichzeitig schreiben und das macht halt die anwendung dass sich
da nix in die quere kommt ist ist im prinzip mehr oder weniger festplatten durchgereicht
und den ich festplanen kann block devices durchgereicht übers netzwerk früher hat man
sowas relativ klassisch über fiber channel gemacht mittlerweile sagt man sich warum sollte
eine eigene infrastruktur hin bauen wenn ich das auch über den switch machen kann
oder über das schon vorhandene aber zum beispiel bei ist was du nicht machen kannst ist dass
zwei benutzer das ganze gleichzeitig verwenden kennst du afs wenn du dieses oracle gedöns
meist dann kenn ich dann kenn ich nur vom sehen bei uns ich hab damit noch nix gemacht
also wie gesagt hier kannst du auch nicht mit zwei leuten gleichzeitig drauf zugreifen
dann geht das ding schlicht und kaputt es sei denn man nimmt in den clusterfile system
oben drauf ja das ist das ist wieder was war was anderes dann aber das hier ist anwendungslogik
die dafür sorgt dass du parallel drauf zugreifen kannst und das hier ist halt einfach ne blöcke
weitergeleitet genauso wie das jeder changer schreibt nein habe ich keine ahnung von ich
kenne mich mit vm auch nicht so gut aus hauptdaten speicher für den anderen server wie wäre
es einfach mit ssd dran gehe ich auch mal von aus dass es dass es gar nicht geht aber
sollte es gehen geht es auf jeden fall kaputt der der große unterschied ist ja auch da
wo man schon sieht was was was da der der der unterschied ist wenn du es csi target
machst da musst du da du musst du ein fallsystem drauf machen hast du einen sammars share da
kannst du direkt auf die dateien zugreifen aber ansonsten ich kann dir leider nichts
wirklich sinnvolles zu raten weil ich nicht großartig muss man felix fragen weil ich
jetzt nicht sonderlich viel staura sachen mache also für meine sachen daheim würde
ich da nichts irgendwie durchreichen da würde ich dem server ssd verpassen und lokal drauf
installieren gut ist habe ich gesehen ist aber immer noch krepp und es ist krepp weil
es immer noch ein code signing zertifikat braucht und sich kein privater hobby entwickler
in 250 euro im jahr code signing zertifikat kauft nur um microsoft zufrieden zu stellen
ziff ist samba das ist das gleiche ich bin mir gar nicht sicher was ist wie es eigentlich
richtig heißt smb zips das ist auf jeden fall alles das gleiche ich weiß dass jetzt gleich
einer ankommt aber max historisch ist das doch ganz anders aber im prinzip ist es das
gleiche so was kann man sonst machen man kann replikation zu machen riese resilver bedeutet
die par zfs machen nennen die sachen ganz ganz gerne anders resilver ist wenn du einen
rate rebuild ist also sprich dir gegen eine festplatte kaputt du machst du erneuer du
du tauscht die festplatte aus dann resilver zfs wohingegen den rate rebuildet das ist
das gleiche so das hier ist aufräumen bisschen zeug um das ist quasi sowas wie defragmentieren
in zfs sprache scrubbing so cloud sync das haben wir nicht network interessiert nicht
storage pools hier wird schon mal interessanter warum steht da nicht das system storage pool
drin da sollte das sollte eigentlich was kann schon das überhaupt ich würde mal sagen alles
was frinas kann bloß ein bisschen mehr hauptsächlich ist das wohl für leute gedacht die zfs verwenden
wollen und auch in also nicht nur für daheim also sprich leute die auch einen pfeilserver
bereitstellen wollen in umgebung wo auch ordentlich was gemacht wird drauf also das
pool steht nicht drin ok snapshots haben auch nicht vor mv was vor mvr snapshots was soll
uns denn das sagen hier das verstehe ich jetzt nicht hier sind ok das sind die richtig
echten platten die drunter sind import disk das muss man glaube ich machen wenn man schon
einen ach nee aber das kann man andere sachen einhängen ok weil unter import verschieden
über zfs eigentlich festplatten wo schon zfs drauf ist was man einfach dann importiert
dass es das erkennt der ziel snapshots von zfs von fernweiser ok gut das lasse jetzt
mal außen vor das interessiert uns jetzt nicht sharing apple shares afp block shares
es csi jones scherz web ach guck mal die können jetzt direkt web darf shares das ist ja interessant
das finde ich cool windows shares das werden wir klein ausprobieren also was ich mal ausprobieren
möchte ist wie es mit zfs mir machen zfs rate 1 und gucken ob man das verschlüsselt
machen kann weil zfs kann ja mittlerweile ja native encryption ich weiß aber nicht ob
das ist zfs von freeBSD mittlerweile kann ok und noch mal für nas pops was ist zfs zfs
hat mit nas an sich erstmal gar nichts zu tun damit im nas versteht versteht ihr einfach
drunter dass du in irgendeine art und weise files übers netzwerk bereitstellst so und zfs
ist ein dateisystem was deutlich mehr kann als so die meisten anderen filesysteme dementsprechend
braucht es aber auch ram es fack also so normales filesystem sagen wir so was wie x4 oder xfs
oder ntfs oder sowas die ein oder anderen features die es bei zfs gibt haben die teilweise
auch aber nicht in nicht in dieser konzentration also zfs ist ein filesystem da hast du beispielsweise
die ganzen rate geschichten schon eingebaut normalerweise wenn du den rate machen willst
brauchst du entweder rate adapter also eine karte die das macht oder host adapter irgendwie
so ein so ein ding brauchst du oder du machst ein software rate also entweder md rate oder
wie heißt das unter windows leute storage storage spaces oder so weißt doch von euch
chat ist doch immer big brain ihr wisst sowas doch storage spaces heißt das glaube ich
unter unter windows ja und bei zfs ist es halt schon gleich mit eingebaut also sprich
du kannst filesystem rate alles in eine machen das ist das ist ganz praktisch zumal der also
der vorteil davon ist halt dass das eine vom anderen weiß dementsprechend kann zfs auch
überprüfen ok sind die dateien nicht nur war sie im index vorhanden sondern sind die
dateien auch wirklich intakt und solche sachen also sprich das macht dann im hintergrund
auch checks um und guckt ok ist die datei auch wirklich die datei die sie sein sollte
und sowas lego zwölf monate exquisite subscription huge so genau wenn es genau wie sie willst
du kannst da 30 milliarden sachen mitmachen blub blub blub blub blub also zfs ist somit
das advanceste datalsystem was du so verwenden kannst ich benutze web darf eigentlich so
gut wie gar nicht das einzige wo ich web darf verwende ist glaube ich zum notizen synchronisieren
aber ansonsten gibt habe ich auch kein kein kein grund also notizen in nextcloud zu synchronisieren
ansonsten habe ich überhaupt keinen anwendungszweck im web darf so services wie überwacht denn
schon seine festplatten s3 samba das schalten wir schon mal ein das brauchen wir nämlich
gleich guck mal das hat jetzt eingebaut ein vpn klein und ein open vpn server ok wenn
ich da jetzt eigentlich weniger vermutet meinen die mit ups eine usb oder ist ups irgendein
anderes storage fachbegriff der mir nix sagt wie kann ich eine usb im webinterface einschalten
wahrscheinlich ist das die dass wenn man die usb per usb angeschlossen hat dass man dann
quasi auslesen kann ob die kapazität zur neige geht und sowas weil ich meine dass man
nicht einfach nur usb im webinterface an und ausschalten kann ist ja logisch ja genau
autoshutdown sowas in der richtung das habe ich mir schon gedacht so tfdp das ist wenn
ich irgendwelche sachen booten will ok plugins you cannot create plugins or jails until pool
is present aber ich kann keinen pool erstellen weil ich keine keine platten drinne habe das
muss ich jetzt gleich machen ich will einfach nur mal angucken was haben wir für was zum
was macht die denn da das ist das ist die bsd container variante hier auch wenn es
da schon länger als containers gibt also man kann quasi so art so art container darauf
starten ok ja gut da hätten sie jetzt halt den vorteil wenn sie linux verwenden da gibt
wahrscheinlich einfach schon deutlich mehr vorgefertigte sachen ja gox ja gut wenn man
es braucht probieren wir gleich mal aus einfach einfach testweise unterstützt er mittlerweile
doch keine ich würde sagen das ist alles das ist alles jails also jails ist ja quasi
das bsd docker nein nicht wirklich die das bsd container ding ich weiß gar nicht gibt
es gibt es gibt es docker für bsd ich meine theoretisch schon docker ist ja nur das frontend
ich könnte mir vorstellen dass es in den docker jails plug in oder so gibt war mich
mir nur nie angeschaut ob sowas keine ahnung zur virtual machines man kann sogar vms drauf
laufen lassen ok gut das werden wir jetzt nicht machen weil nested virtualisierung
dauert wieder drei stunden alles klar display system processes moment wie man einfach mal
eine scheld kriegt lull das ist bestimmt nicht so gedacht oder na gut aber der untreute
kriegt er direkt ohne schell warum nicht das ist praktisch das gab es vorher noch nicht
in der version die ich verwendet habe da muss man sich immer per ssh verbinden wenn man
ein bisschen was größeres macht ist über ssh auch angenehmer weil die ganzen wahrscheinlich
auch nicht richtig copy pasten drin und sonst was aber so eine shell zu haben im webinterface
ist definitiv nicht verkehrt ist dann schunas quasi ein proxmox konkurrent nee ich würde
sagen das hat überschneidung dadurch aber das bedient komplett unterschiedliche geschichten
wohingegen proxmox eindeutig zu 95 prozent für virtualisierung und container gedürnt
ist ist schon erst für 95 prozent für netzwerk storage und fünf prozent für ein bisschen
virtualisierungs graben also ich würde sagen das ist hat überschneidung aber ist komplett
andere richtung das ist das merkt ihr auch immer in der oberfläche hier schon wir können
wir können es mit nested virtualisierung gleich mal probieren ja wir können wir können es
gleich mal ausprobieren ob das funktioniert aber ich könnte wetten dass das ganze vorne
vom management her nicht so schön ist ja jetzt jetzt liegen wir erstmal ein paar jetzt jetzt
machen wir erstmal jetzt adden wir erstmal ein paar festplatten gucken ob das funktioniert
so settings add disk excellent jawoll create new disk jawoll 8g reicht vollkommen aus jawoll
so speichert ihr die denn da soll das in e vms da soll das drin speichern disk 1 finish
noch eine disk disk 2 so haben wir zwei platten dran gemacht das für den rate 1 sollte das
reichen und wir können hier kommen wir machen drei wir machen wir machen den rate 1 ist
ja in den rate 5 quasi den zfs mirror ist in rate 1 krieg ich das richtig zusammen zfs
mirror ist in rate 1 und zfs rate 1 ist in rate 5 so rum wir machen wir machen rate 5
so zack zack zack zack disk 3 big brain benahmung sebaru wir können auch in rate 6 machen das
dann glaube ich in zfs rate 2 zufällig erfahrung bezüglich pki lösung gar nicht wirklich
also bei uns auf der arbeit machen wir das ziemlich low brain mit so einem juby key stick
und dann gibt es ab und zu mal ein paar neue keys also es ist nicht sonderlich etwas zu
wieder treiben so also mal gucken ob der jetzt die platten erkannt hat ich habe hier neue
disks reingemacht storage disks hey guck mal da man muss nichts restarten man muss nichts
refreshen er muss nicht 50 mal speichern wie in open media vault eigentlich ganz gut
titan toaster zwei monat habe ich gar nicht übersehen dankeschön für den sub
ich gucke nachher noch mal den chat durch kann sein dass ich ein bisschen was übersehen
haben willst dir omv schlecht reden die omv hat sich selbst schlecht gemacht als ich ausprobiert
habe es hat mir gar nicht gefallen ich sage nicht dass es keiner verwenden soll aber mir
hat es überhaupt nicht gefallen so also jetzt können pool anlegen add und hauen die ganzen
drei platten rein so create new storage pool ach hier kann man importieren wenn man platten
dran hängt die schon was haben okay das ist nicht schlecht create new storage pool also
ich muss sagen für solche ich habe in letzter zeit auch ein bisschen mit beautify rum gebastelt
das ist ja auch so ein material design framework aber ich bin für mich persönlich zu dem schluss
gekommen dass ich finde dass web anwendungen durch material design eher unübersichtlicher
werden man merkt dass es eigentlich für kleine kleinere displays und mobile anwendung mobile
anwendung gedacht ist ich finde in web anwendung werden durch material design irgendwie die
sehen so zerstöckelt aus wisst ihr was ich meine das sieht so unzusammenhängend aus
und so und so so zu so zerteilt und und wo man gar nicht genau weiß wo man jetzt hin
soll phoenix sagt hallo fünf monat dankeschön für den sub exquisite subscription siehe siehe
neuer skin von ich kenne den neuen skin von facebook nicht facebook hat neuen skin ich
war fünf jahre nicht mehr auf facebook wie sieht Facebook jetzt aus ich wusste dir dass
ich eine facebook seite habe boomer fps am facebook seite habe ich mir irgendwann gemacht
als facebook so im trend war das sieht auch genauso aus wie vorher also das letzte was
ich auf facebook gepostet habe von 2018 ok das sieht auch genauso aus wie vorher oder
muss man da irgendwie new machen ich weiß doch mein password nicht wenn ich bin powered
by alienware was habe ich das vergessen rauszunehmen
wusste ich gar nicht weil ich habe mit alienware nie was gemacht
ich muss jetzt gerade mal kurz in meine mails nebenbei reingucken was habe ich denn mit
alienware gemacht warum bin ich denn angeblich powered by alienware wtf also ich weiß ich
wollte mal mit alienware was machen aber ok alienware
wtf ich hab mit denen auch irgendwas gemacht aber
ich habe keine ahnung so ich habe pflegt immer durch wie dem auch sei
jetzt habe ich jetzt habe ich natürlich verkackt ich muss euch mal kurz ausschalten ich habe
Sachen aus der mail copy paste die sind jetzt wahrscheinlich im clipboard manager exquisite
also ich habe gelernt ich bin ich bin powered by alienware ja ich habe glaube ich auch mal
mit alienware was ich kann mich da überhaupt nicht mehr dran erinnern ich hab was ich hab
echt alienware auf youtube verlinkt wirklich ach scheiß drauf ist egal sollte ich mal
die zugangsdaten wieder finden dann mache ich das raus
tatsächlich ja da habe ich auf alienware verlinkt ich weiß nicht mehr wie dem auch sein wir
machen jetzt einfach weiter irgendwas alles aus grauer vorzeit da so also wie funktioniert
das jetzt genau also wir machen die disks in rate 1 ok wie funktioniert das name cute
chat aber man kann direkt encryption anmachen das ist schon mal praktisch yes ich ich understande
komplett wo wo gibt man das moment wo gibt man das passwort ein ist dabei ist für für
den key backappen wenn ich das die installation wegschmeißen ok wie geht es jetzt wie geht
es jetzt weiter um ein spinn verwirrt was watte ich will das data adden hier auf den
fall in dem video wird fett alienware eingeblendet was ja vielleicht habe ich doch mal was mit
alienware gemacht und ich kann mich einfach nur nicht mehr dran erinnern wo wo blend ich
alienware ein da unten what the fuck warum habe ich echt mal was mit alienware gemacht
ich weiß es wirklich nicht mehr feinst schämen ach und hier kann man auswählen was es gibt
ok stripe das ist rate 0 mirror ist in rate 1 und z rate ist in rate 5 wenn ich mehrere
disks adden würde könnte ich auch z rate 1 2 3 wahrscheinlich machen ok zfs rate machen
und jetzt kann man create machen encryption ist schon mal gut ja ok das ist gut da sagt
mir jetzt wenn ich diesen key verliere natürlich wollen wir den nicht downloaden wenn ich diesen
key verliere kann ich nie wieder die festplatten entschlüsseln das ist gut dass sie das so
wie soll man sagen prominent machen weil ich neige bei sowas auch immer das zu vergessen
beziehungsweise zu ignorieren was sagt denn suggest layout gute frage wahrscheinlich
dass ich dass ich einen stripe machen soll oder einen mirror machen soll mit zwei oder
so keine ahnung kann ich jetzt auch nicht mal ausprobieren weil es ist zu spät jetzt
habe ich schon geedit vielleicht kann man noch mal editieren edit options ne ah ok hier
kann man einstellen ob er standardmäßig compression macht ok die application das
ist eine sache die würde ich nie einschalten außer ich weiß wirklich was ich mache weil
die application bei zfs brauche ram ohne ende oder es ist lahm ohne ende ne die muss
man nicht per passport entsperren das geht über den key aber wenn ich das system lösche
und ich die platten an ein anderes hängen will muss ich diesen key vorher exportieren
importieren das ist das was er eben auch gerade mit dem popup gesagt hat ok die application
oft das ist auf jeden fall sinnvoll kann man kann zfs mittlerweile volumes hinzufügen nicht
volume devices zu volumes hinzufügen das geht ja das ging ja eigentlich nie und es
war auch bei design so nie geplant aber ich habe gelesen irgendwo bei zfs und nidus dass
sie das einbauen wollen weiß ich ob das vielleicht mittlerweile eingebaut ist geht
nicht so richtig ok also wir haben jetzt erstmal einen pool angelegt also ich kann den jetzt
auch nicht mehr großartig editieren das ist jetzt vorbei doch oder ach ne da müsste ich
einfach neue neue hinzufügen oder oder was auch immer das weiß ich dass man das durch
größere ersetzen kann ja stimmt das ging ja schon immer aber man kann wohl oder sie
wollten das machen das habe ich vor vor zwei jahren oder so gelesen bei zfs und nidus dass
du wirklich platten hinzufügen kannst also dass du sagen kannst ok aus dem pool mit
drei platten wird jetzt einer mit vier platten und sowas ich weiß aber nicht ob da jeweils
was draus geworden ist so also wir haben standardmäßig compression an compression ist so eine geschichte
die kann man eigentlich relativ bedenkenlos bei jedem halbwegs aktuellen nasse oder bei
jeder halbwegs aktuellen hardware einschalten weil compression geht ziemlich schnell ok
also dann machen wir mal einen zamba share und greifen mit windows drauf zu ob das funktioniert
windows share add ich habe bestimmt noch irgendwas vergessen oh was will ok was will der von
mir cute chat ahja cute chat will ich hinzufügen das ist mein pool advanced options da sind
diese ekligen zamba options wo ich immer irgendwas verkehrtes anhake allow guest access genau
kann ich anonym drauf zugreifen wunderbar submit ok jetzt schauen wir mal ob das funktioniert
enable service das macht mich jetzt echt ganz wir dass ich dass ich auf meiner facebook
seite noch stehen habe das von alienware gesponsert wurde ich habe doch nie mit alienware was
gemacht warum habe ich die im video stehen das verwirrt mich wie kann ich die sachen
so vergessen obwohl die erst zwei oder drei jahre her sind ok eher drei jahre her sind
wie warum bin ich wie low brain kann man sein du hast das profilakt ich kann mich noch daran
erinnern dass das nicht zustande gekommen ist und sich der der der typ der das vermitteln
wollte dann irgendwie raus geredet hat oder gesagt nicht so schnell was auch immer und
dann wollten sie irgendwas was ich nicht wollte oder so keine ahnung aber ich ändert das
jetzt auch nicht weil wenn ich das jetzt ändere dann postet facebook immer ein update immer
wenn man seinen profil ändert auf facebook postet ist ein update das will ich nicht da
denken die leute ich mache da irgendwas ups moment vielleicht soll ich mal richtig schreiben
so cute chat das immer das war easy also drei platten reingesteckt zfs rate encrypted und
ein samba sharehammer am start das finde ich gut mal gucken wie schnell wir sind das ist
jetzt nicht wirklich repräsentativ ich meine ich kopiere also ich kopiere von meinem rechner
auf meinen rechner quasi übers netzwerk dass das aka ich darf da nichts schreiben ok gest
exes ist read only dann müssen wir erst einmal einstellen ok samba settings wo kann man das
jetzt einstellen ich will einfach gast a guest exes right right read haben die falsche parameters
was files bekommen read only after s after five minutes das ist bestimmt ganz gut wenn
man nicht will dass der eine dem anderen was kaputt macht ok ich glaube hier geht das
nicht advanced options also gest exes hammer an dann ist das dass ich darf keine sache
von samba sondern eine sache von filesystem permission full change everyone ja gut jetzt
habe ich keine ahnung was ich machen muss dass ich für alle freigeben kann weil anlegen
darf ich nix hier drauf offensichtlich beim smb service gab es noch mehr optionen echt
wo die basic options wieder zurück da ist jetzt aber eigentlich nix für berechtigung
drinne ah same as the guest account gest exes also das heißt ich gehe jetzt mal auf accounts
und gucke ob da der guest account drinne steht was gehen wir zurück zu storage das ist auch
nicht read only also same as guest account account users guests gibts nicht ok all built
in users are hidden ok ich soll das toggeln wo ist guest guesst guesst gibts nicht guest
gibts nicht gut dann legen wir jetzt einfach mal den user an und geben dem rechte da drauf
ja ja halt weil eigentlich mit guest user würde ich sonst eh nicht machen vielleicht
als gruppe ne was da steht dass es kleinzeitig ist berechtigung können nicht kleinzeitig
sein das wäre fail ach das haben die auf nobody gemapt ok das könnte natürlich auch sein
ne haben aber auch nicht doch hä ok dynamisches geladenes zeug ja aber
irgendwelche file access sachen kann ich da doch nicht einstellen ok wisst ihr was wir
machen das jetzt mal ich lege mir meinen neuen user an so user max 1 2 3 4 5 6 1 2 3 4 5
6 new group primary group kann ich so sagen admin muss ich das in die sammergruppe packen
dass der überhaupt darf ok das erscheint mir jetzt bissl zu ne oder muss ich wahrscheinlich
nicht build in guessts ach guck mal hier directory und permissions cute chat so read write alles
bamm ok dann probieren wir das nochmal jetzt habe ich meinen user angelegt der auf dem
ding alles darf gehen wir nochmal in shares stellen jetzt gast access ne moment the fuck
wo war das hier machen wir gast access aus und jetzt muss ich jetzt muss ich mich da
noch irgendwie da hinzufügen wahrscheinlich oder die berechtigung hängen am pool user
quotas ok wo auch immer was ich hab doch gast access ausgeschaltet was hä warum darf ich
denn da drinnen jetzt was machen ich bin überhaupt nicht als max angemeldet ok ich
bin ich zu small brain für das zu verstehen ok schauen wir mal wie schnell das ganze kopiert
ich kann ja offensichtlich was anlegen es kopiert ja gut in die vm von der vm übrigens
das ist ne magnet festplatte wo das ganze also das ist ne olle festplatte wo das ganze
drauf liegt das ist irgendeine wd 6 terabyte sonst was ich mein der liest und schreibt
davon aber es funktioniert ok gut stimmt ich habe gesagt jeder darf in mein home schreiben
aber ich verstehe nicht warum ich in mein home schreiben darf aber da nicht obwohl da
gast access drauf ist stimmt weil ich die berechtigung für des obergeordnete nicht
gesetzt habe das wird sein da müsste ich nur müsste ich nur feststellen wo man das wo
man das machen darf ein user quotas werden es nicht sein ich brauche ein data set ok
exquisite wo mache ich das jetzt das das habe ich das habe ich schon mal gesehen hier irgendwo
irgendwo gab es die great great data set data set name lulvi so sync standard ja gut exis
time braucht kein mensch ist auch encrypted share type samba kann man das direkt ausstellen
einstellen ok teeth application auf gar keinen fall berechtigung kann man hier nicht machen
aber wahrscheinlich kann man jetzt berechtigung machen edit permissions aha das sieht doch
jetzt schon besser aus so und da schreiben wir jetzt rein user guest oder so aber den
gibt es ja nicht was nobody aber ich kann mich da jetzt eintragen max max darf das hätten
aber da hätten wir es den leute tatsächlich ein bisschen einfacher machen können weil
das ja im prinzip ganz normale filesystem berechtigung sind wo man den web interface
drüber gemacht hat jawoll brauchen wir nicht gibt es nur das also ohne lau lau was immer
safe exisit sehen wir das jetzt schon irgendwo aha jetzt darf ich sagen max 1 2 3 4 5 6
bäm alles klar aber in meiner
der username ist max das vorname nachname ok das ist auf jeden fall auf jeden fall was
womit man sich ein bisschen mehr beschäftigen muss dass man es kapiert was macht die option
exisit haben dann exisit haben sorgt dafür dass der speichert wann zuletzt zugegriffen
wurde auf dateien darf ich auch nicht aber ich darf in meiner heimat verzeichnen das
ist ja schon mal was ich glaube aber das ist gar nicht so kompliziert wenn man sich ein
bisschen beschäftigt hat und da kommt man denke ich relativ einfach dahinter was passiert
eigentlich was passiert eigentlich wenn ich als root ane ok das geht auch nicht das geht
auch nicht aber ich kann wieder ich kann in samba share reingehen und dort wieder sagen
ich will wieder enable für guest exisit machen so und jetzt kann ich auch wieder dahin auch
nicht warum das denn jetzt nicht ah jetzt gehts wieder ok so und jetzt kann ich hier
dinger drinnen treiben ne keine ahnung ok was auch immer man muss sich im detail angucken
aber ich glaube dann blickt man durch wenn man sich das angeguckt hat so wir wollen ja
noch ein paar andere sachen ausprobieren ich kann jetzt nicht jede halbe stunde kann
das eigentlich mittlerweile noch andere das samba share zeigt auf das pool nicht das stimmt
das müssen wir umhängen wir müssen dem sagen hier nicht geh nicht auf mount sondern geh
auf 0w und dann hängt er unseren samba share um oder sollte eigentlich also müsste er aber
macht er irgendwie nicht ok vielleicht muss ich mal samba neu starten oder so dass er
das dass er das checkt probieren wir das mal aus plugins ne nicht plugins services wann
hast du das letzte mal getanzt weißt du richtig echt real life also so richtig echt so also
so so irgendwelche paar tanzgeschichten so irgendwie habe ich das habe ich noch nie
probiert habe ich da habe ich noch nie probiert habe ich aber auch noch nie irgendwie großartigen
dazugehabt also tanzen zu lernen da habe ich doch noch nie dran gedacht dass zum das
mal zu lernen so samba restarten stopp gibt sich einfach restarten knopf so und jetzt
hütscher auf hütscher wo bist du das erzählen wir nix aber ich habe es kaputt gemacht warum
geht der timeout nicht weil twitch dich gebadet weil twitch diese option anzeigt aber wenn
kein mod da ist der das macht wirst du nicht timeout das ist nix automatisches das ist
einfach nur twitch gebadet im zweifel ist windows verwirrt ja das kann auch sein contact
your network administrator aber wisst ihr was wir machen was immer gut ist wollte immer
ausprobieren ob das funktioniert restart bam confirm ah ne jetzt habe ich gekancelt restart
confirm restart oh komm mal die haben sogar so ein restarting splash screen ne der dark
mod hat mir nicht so gut gefällt ich kann gleich noch mal dark mod machen ist das nicht
off center es könnte ein bisschen weiter rechts sein oder
es ist ein bisschen weiter rechts als links oder mir kommt es minimal weiter rechts vor
als links oder sitzt ich schämen ne das ist ein bisschen weiter rechts als links konnte
man sich nicht irgendwie die abstände anzeigen lassen oh jetzt vorbei das ist jetzt center
windows ist verwirrt windows mag nicht mehr windows windows hat kein bock mehr share kaputt
windows verwirrt ja es kann aber auch sein dass wir es kaputt gemacht haben indem wir
das umgehängt haben ich hänge es mal wieder zurück ich hänge es mal wieder zurück auf
q chat ob es dann geht ja es könnte auch sein dass nobody nicht von uns ne jetzt ist windows
ist verwirrt aber scheiß drauf windows kann ruhig verwirrt sein so aber sammars shares
funktionieren prinzipiell und ich finde auch die verwaltung hier über das web interface
gar nicht so übel man muss sich halt mal in ruhe mit beschäftigen so web
das muss ich jetzt mal ausprobieren ob man da irgendwie es ist zwar total hängen geblieben
mich interessiert einfach ob es funktioniert es gibt noch andere sachen die wir ausprobieren
können aber das interessiert mich jetzt wirklich ob das funktioniert wir machen jetzt wir legen
jetzt eine vm an und hin zu den trunas in trunas nehmen installieren was war in ubuntu oder
oder ne tiny core oder irgendwas irgendwas kleines irgendwas kleines was ist denn so
die kleinste live cd die euch einfällt wobei live cd bringt eh nix frinas tiny core core
aha basti das ist aber auch irgendwie windows logik oder da braucht eine ganz schöne weile
zum starten ok bist du wieder da root so was machen wir alerts ich habe repooted monka
s zack dark theme koketa pool da ist er das finde ich aber ganz gut dass sie so ein dashboard
haben wo man direkt hinkommt hier sieht man dann beispielsweise auch bei zfs zumindest
auf der kommando zeit ich denke mal dass es hier wäre weniger so ein rapper um die kommando
zeit ausgabe ist da sieht man dann auch wenn disks gefällt sind und ob der irgendwelche
anderen fehler hat und man kann auch hier direkt sagen ok die platte ist noch nicht
kaputt aber ich will sie jetzt gleich austauschen so snapshots kann man machen gut so wir probieren
erst mal dieses tschüss tschüss ok da haben wir nicht all zu viel platz weil wir haben
nur acht gigabyte platten drin aber nur mal testweise ich mache jetzt einfach mal irgendwie
so das ist dieser das ist quasi die freebsd docker variante install pog pogu verwendet
das überhaupt noch jemand oh er dockert bzw er gild gild postchamp genau wir installieren
temple os der postchamp aber ganz schön lang wie lange dauert so was in der regel
ein bisschen inkonsistent ist das ganze ja auch ich mein hier gibt es den install popup
und hier oben gibt es was wo ich die services übersicht habe
ich habe das gefühl das funktioniert nicht ich habe irgendwie so das die leichte vermutung
ist was kaputt gegen lassen wir den mal sein ding machen wow looking for help ja also das
hat ihn schon mal absolut nicht gejuckt der hat einfach nichts gemacht das war dem egal
ok dann legen wir mal noch vm an das funktioniert wir haben nested virtualisierung bootmethode
nein was krabb ich linux blub bein ja ok next next discs create new disc auch guck mal da
kann sogar wird exquisite ja wir haben leider nicht so viel platz next next installation
media aber kann installen upload ok das ist praktisch also wir brauchen jetzt mal irgendwas
zum testen irgendwas irgendwas kleines ne und put es aber nicht sein tiny core oder
irgendwas ich will einfach nur mein iso einlegen gucken ob es funktioniert download save so
also downloads das haben sie aber gut gemacht dass du an der stelle gleich das iso hochladen
kannst das ist ganz praktisch es funktioniert auch ach hier so submit ok das funktioniert
schon mal nett aber wie dem außen ist auch das spiel rei das würde ich da wahrscheinlich
eh nicht drauf laufen lassen ehrlich gesagt aber warum warum das kann sein dass nested
virtualisierung ich meint dis name already exists sagte moment der hat ein anderes problem
war blub blub dann mein pfing da drin installation media
Was hat er für Schmerzen?
Ah, meine Festplatte ist zu groß.
Äh, wie kann ich ihm denn sagen, was er für eine Festplatte ist?
Hier.
Eins.
Ein G.
Kann ich G reinschreiben?
Ein G, Next, Next, Next, Submit, ah, yes, geht immer noch nicht, Name already exists,
Alter, nervt nicht rum.
Warum ist das so bescheuert und behält das nachdem es fehlgeschlagen ist?
Bug, ja, aha, bam, da sind wir, 0W ist gestartet.
So, ähm, wie lösche ich den Kram jetzt?
Da sind nämlich die alten, Delete, die gibt's, Moment, ich darf sie nicht Copy-Paste, ah,
outplayed, outplayed, guck mal, schaff zu, ok, ich kann ja nicht mal Vms löschen, perfekt.
State, stopped, on, jawoll, so, gibt's jetzt eine Konsole, VNC, boah, Poggers, guck mal,
es funktioniert.
Da, guckt euch mal an, äh, also so wirklich hat's nicht gestartet, aber ich hab eine Vm
in einer Vm, Moment, ich hab in einer Vm nass, in dem eine Vm läuft.
Ja, gut, ja, warum der nicht bootet ist mir jetzt nicht ganz klar, aber soll jetzt auch
nicht unser, unser Problem sein, kann Teiniko, ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung, ich glaube,
er hat den Installer schon wieder verworfen, ne, Crap, warum kann er nicht, Bios, wo mach
ich jetzt das Installer-Media rein, kann ich irgendwie Installer einlegen oder so, hier
vielleicht, ne, das geht hier drüber nicht, würde Trunas auch auf dem Raspberry Pi laufen,
gute Frage, wahrscheinlich nicht, aber möglich, möglich ist es, Devices, CD-ROM, Edit, ne,
hat das ISO drinnen, aber, aber immerhin, kann man ein VLC irgendwie, Control-Alt entfernen
schicken, Connect, okay, ach, egal, also Vms, Vms funktionieren prinzipiell, aber ich glaube,
die Verwaltung ist wirklich nicht schön, also da ist, also da sieht man auch wieder,
dass es halt echt nicht mit Proxmox konkurrieren will, ne, Proxmox ist halt 95% Virtualisierung,
wogegen das hier halt 95% nass ist und gibt da ein paar Überschneidungen, so, also das
hier hat ja absolut, das hier hat ja gar nicht funktioniert, boah, hat der lang gebraucht,
guck mal, jetzt ist er am Start, jetzt ist er am Start und läuft sogar, das hat ja irgendwie
eine halbe Stunde gebraucht, bis das installiert war, Pogu kommt wieder weg, Delete, gibt's
ein Armbild davon, das ist halt deshalb die Frage, ob's das überhaupt geht, ich glaube,
dass da gar kein Armbild für gibt, is it possible, guck mal doch mal, was die, was
die da auf Reddit zu sagen, no, okay, nein, geht nicht, gibt kein Armbild, also kannst
es auch nicht auf Raspberry Pi laufen lassen, würdest du tun, was für den Urteil tatsächlich,
nö, weil es kein Armbild gibt, also hast du gelitten, gibt's nicht, ach, für den H2+,
ja, das kannst du machen, das kannst du machen, aber ganz ehrlich, ich persönlich bin ja immer
noch ein Fan von einfach gar keine Nass-Distribution zu verwenden, sondern einfach, stinkt noch
mal, einen Samba-Server zu installieren, um gut ist, es sei denn, also, wenn man wirklich
jetzt größere Sperenzien machen will mit ZFS und sich damit nicht beschäftigen will,
wie es auf der Kommando-Zeile geht, okay, dann kann ich's verstehen, aber für alles
andere, wie gesagt, ich hab hier auf der Kiste, die neben mir steht, hab ich ja auch ein Ubuntu-Server
drauf, ein paar Container laufen, ein Samba für File-Share und Gutes, ja, Nextcloud fliegt
bei mir, Beatport, Nextcloud fliegt bei mir demnächst wieder raus, weil ich keine Verwendung
hab für, this folder is empty, excellent, ah, jetzt geht's wieder nicht, what, Windows,
please, weil ich keine Verwendung hab für 90% der Nextcloud-Geschichten, also, und ich
finde halt auch, dass bei Nextcloud vieles total unfertig ist, wie gesagt, eine Notizen-App,
wo man nicht richtig durchsuchen kann oder so, also Sebaro, ich finde, man braucht kein
Interface, wie gesagt, es sei denn, man möchte wirklich irgendwelche komplizierteren Sachen
machen, also ZFS mit Encryption und dann auch irgendwelche, keine Ahnung, Snapshot-Tasks
und sowas, da ist das hier bestimmt ganz cool, aber wenn man einfach nur einen Ordner
freigeben will, viel mehr will ich ja nicht, von meinem File-Server hier lokal bei mir,
da reicht mir mein selbstinstallierter Samba und gut ist, und das ganze geht per R-Sync
einmal nachts auf eine externe USB-Festplatte und gut ist, ich hab das einfachste Setup,
was irgendwie, was man nur haben kann, nachdem ich da meine fette 4 HE-Kiste mit mehreren
10 TB Platten drinnen hatte und das war dann am Ende so kompliziert, das ganze Teil, dass
ich selbst einmal durchgeblickt hab und ich wusste, wenn ich das ausschalte, kann ich
nicht mehr mal die Rollos hoch und runter machen, weil da alles drauf läuft.
Was für ein Board hast du bei deinem NAS, denn wie gesagt, ich hab hier keinen, ich
hab hier nicht wirklich einen NAS im eigentlichen Sinne gebaut, ich hab einen stromsparenden
Intel Low-Power-Server gebaut mit dem billigsten Board und dem billigsten Gehäuse, was ich
gefunden hab.
Als Board ist das drinnen, ne nicht S-Rock, doch S-Rock, Moment, aber nicht das hier,
sondern fast, fast das hier, wenn ich jetzt noch auf die Kategorie wechseln könnte, ja,
die S-Rock Seite ist nicht so geil, Products, Motherboards, Intel CPU, ich glaube das hier,
was ist das Board, was ich da drinnen hab und wenn die Bude abfackelt, inklusive Exzender
Platten, hast du noch ein Offside-Backup, ja, aber wirklich nur für das Allerwichtigste,
das ist nicht viel, ich hab beispielsweise mein Passwortsafe noch Offside-Backup, Passwortsafe
hab ich Offside-Backup, ich hab nen Dampf von meinem iPhone noch Offside-Backup, aber wirklich
nur das wenigste, das Allerwichtigste, genau das Board ist das was ich aktuell drin hab,
da gibt es jetzt übrigens was neues, Intel hat jetzt die Nachfolge CPUs angekündigt
davon, warte du benutzt dein Passwortsafe privat, klar warum nicht, Passwortsafe ist
das sinnvollste was du machen kannst, ich benutze KeyPass, aber KeyPass, die Produktkategorie
nennt sich halt nur mal Passwortsafe, ich nehm KeyPass, also ich benutze nicht ein Produkt
was ich Passwortsafe nennt, ich sage zu KeyPass halt einfach Passwortsafe, was wir heute,
wir haben uns, wir haben uns oder wir gucken uns grad das, die neue Preview Variante von
TrueNAS an, nein ich mein nicht das Produkt Passwortsafe, das Produkt Passwortsafe haben
wir auf der Arbeit und das ist das schlimmste, der schlimmste, unübersichtlichste, V8 oder
sowas, das schlimmste und unübersichtlichste Produkt zum Passwaterspeicher was ich mir
vorstellen kann, das ist so ne typische Stonks Windows Anwendung, die keiner anschafft der
noch bei sinnen ist und sie benutzen muss, guckt euch das mal an, alter Monarch S, was
ist das hier, das ist Paints, das ist wirklich extremer Paints Champ sowas, hier so sieht
das aus, alter was ist das für ne Oberfläche, das ist so ne, das ist Ribbon Style mit UWP
und nicht gekonnt, meine Güte ey, ja und das ist das Ding was wir auf der Arbeit haben
und alter ich hab, diese Software ist so dermaßen kacke, die ist genauso kacke wie sie aussieht,
ja extrem übersichtlich ist sie, extrem übersichtlich, schon sehr nice ne, übrigens wisst ihr was
witzig ist, diese Software hier, die ist ja so kacke, dass die Leute die auf der Arbeit
teilweise auch nicht verwenden und jetzt haben die Leute teilweise eigene Keypass Dinger,
weil sie diese Software halt so kacke finden, was ich auch verstehen kann, ich würd die
auch nicht verwenden und wir hatten ja letztens einen Verschlüsselungs Trojaner, der ein
paar Sachen verschlüsselt hat und der hat jetzt auch die ganzen privaten Keypass von
den Leuten verschlüsselt und jetzt hast du manche Leute, die nicht mehr an ihre Sachen
rankommen, weil das der einzige Keypass war, den es gegeben hat, ja, ganz schön verkackt
ey, keine Backups, nein, ja wahrscheinlich schon, aber die Idee dahinter war die Backups
nicht herzustellen, weil man nicht weiß genau, äh quasi ab wann sich dieses Trojaner Ding
verbreitet hat ey, ja aber mittlerweile, mittlerweile haben die Leute so weit, ich weiß, sogar
wieder teilweise ihr Zeug, ja, aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass die Keypass und so nicht
wieder herstellen, weil die Leute haben natürlich Keypass nicht dort gespeichert, wo gebackupt
würde, weil es hieß ja, man soll keine eigenen Passwortmanager verwenden, tja, ganz schön
verkackt, welches Linux verwendest du, das ist Manjaro Linux mit i3 WM, also Leute, ich
weiß jetzt echt nicht, was ich bei TrueNAS noch großartig ausprobieren soll, äh deswegen
guck ich mal durch, ob ich irgendwelche Sachen im Chat übersehen hab, ja, das war ja auch
das geile, die Linux Sachen waren nicht betroffen und by the way, ich weiß nicht, ob ich es
schon erzählt hab, ähm sie sind jetzt auf die glorreiche Idee gekommen, weil Windows
Server Verschlüsselungstrojaner hatten bei uns auf der Arbeit, haben sie sich gesagt,
ok, Windows war betroffen, Linux war nicht betroffen, wir ersetzen jetzt noch weitere
Linux Systeme durch Windows, wo ich mich auch gefragt hab, was ist das für eine Logik,
so nach dem Motto, wir haben einmal aufs Maul gehauen bekommen, wir lassen uns jetzt aber
auf die andere Seite aufs Maul, ich verstehs nicht, also ich kanns mir, doch ich kanns
mir so ein bisschen zusammenreimen, weil die haben sich Microsoft Support geholt für,
für diese Fileserver TrueNAS Geschichte, die sie da hatten und wahrscheinlich hat da
Microsoft Support gesagt, in einer heterogenen Windows, nee warte mal, heterogen bedeutet,
unterschiedlich oder gleich, ok, big brain, Fremdwörter, exquisite, aber wahrscheinlich
hat Microsoft gesagt, ja in einer Windows-only Umgebung, da ist natürlich noch viel mehr
möglich und ähm homogen meine ich, homogene, in einer homogenen Windows Umgebung wäre
natürlich noch viel mehr möglich, irgendwie sowas müssen die erzählt haben und jetzt
werden einige Linux Systeme, die nicht betroffen waren, dass die einzige Systeme dieser Art
waren, die funktioniert haben, werden jetzt durch Windows ersetzt, nachdem man Probleme
hat mit Windows Viren, dabei das Leute klingt doch mal ganz stark nach Stonks Enterprise
Business oder, bestimmt hat sowas der ein oder andere von euch auch schon erlebt in
der Richtung, deswegen ich, ich mach mir da mittlerweile echt keine Gedanken mehr drum,
Hauptsache sie überweisen das gar nicht, wirklich, die Logik muss ich nicht verstehen,
ich will die Logik auch gar nicht mehr verstehen, da gibt es auch nichts zu verstehen, ne, ja
zumindest hat Intel vor ein paar Tagen die Nachfolger-CPUs von denen, von diesen Low-Power-Sachen
angekündigt, ich finde die Boards hier wirklich gut, deswegen habe ich ja auch so ein Board
hier mal gekauft für meine billigste Server-Kiste, die hier gerade neben mir steht, warum ich
die nicht im Rack hängen habe, keine Ahnung, genug Platz ist eigentlich, was, wieso hast
du kein, was für ein Ding, Stonks im Twitch habe ich, meine Stonks gehen laufend hoch,
ja, also wo war ich gerade dabei, genau deswegen habe ich mir für meine billig Kiste hier
auch so ein Board gekauft, die verbrauchen so gut wie gar nichts, ich habe als Netzteil
so ein Teil da drin, glaube so eins, glaube so eins, das ist das Netzteil was ich da drin
habe, und ja das sieht echt so aus, im Prinzip ist es einfach nur ein ATX-Stecker, ein ATX-Stecker
mit einem Hohlstecker für ein Netzteil was dann an die Wand kommt, das Netzteil habe
ich dran und da habe ich dann irgendeinen, frag mich nicht, irgendeinen, irgendwie so
was, irgendwie so ein anderes Teil noch dran, zumindest verbrauchen die Boards tatsächlich
unglaublich wenig, es sieht safe aus, ist safe, ist safe, also die Dinger gibt es schon
lange, habe ich auch ein paar davon, die sind auch relativ beliebt und bekannt, also da muss
man sich keine Gedanken machen, dass die irgendwie abfackeln, das gute ist, ich gucke jetzt mal
kurz auf den Stromverbrauch, das braucht, wohlgemerkt man muss sagen, ich habe doch sogar noch ein
paar Bilder davon, wo ich das Teil zusammenfasse, das sieht wirklich absolut abenteuerlich aus,
also ich habe jetzt wirklich, ich bin von 100, ich bin nicht von 0 auf 100, ich bin von 100
auf 0, wie gesagt ich bin von sowas hier, ich bin von sowas hier, 4 HE, sogar richtig
schön mit Staubfiltern, mehrere 10TB Platten, SSDs, SAS, Raid Controllers, zig Gedulds,
und sowas, bin ich jetzt gewechselt auf, Moment, wo habe ich hier noch ein Bild von, ich hatte
doch hier, bin ich jetzt gewechselt auf sowas, ok, das ist wo ich einfach alles in ein Gehäuse
geschmissen habe, ja, ja und es sieht zwar abenteuerlich, aber es tut, es geht, also
es sieht schlimmer aus als es ist, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich noch ein paar Bilder davon
habe, ah ja, so sieht es jetzt aus, hier habe ich einfach alles reingeschmissen, so sieht
es jetzt aus und zwar, hier ist das Netzteil, man sieht es hier glaube ich, guck hier da,
man sieht es ein bisschen rausgucken, hier sieht man es besser, hier ist das Netzteil,
da ist eine 10 Gigabit Netzwerkkarte drin, mit SFP+, ist ein bisschen, man muss ja sagen,
es ist ein bisschen Overkill dafür, weil das Board an sich hat nur einen PCI Express 2
Board mit 4 Lanes, also da kriege ich überhaupt keine 10 Geh durch, da kriege ich im besten
Fall glaube ich 6 Geh durch, aber ich wollte es haben, weil es geht, ja und außerdem habe
ich davor noch ein paar Karten, aber alle mal besser, alle mal besser als 1 Geh, braucht
man, braucht man eigentlich, ist eigentlich total bescheuert, wenn man sich so überlegt,
dann, so hier ist eine, hier ist eine 12 Terabyte Platte drin und eine SSD und jede Menge USB
für mein Heimautomatisierungszeug, so und das ganze Ding verbraucht jetzt gerade, Moment,
ich fahre nochmal hin, eben waren es 12, 13,7 Watt, wohlgemerkt mit 10 Gehkarte und Platte
IDLE, also die Platte läuft gerade nicht, die IDLE vor sich hin im Standby und da kannst
du wirklich nichts sagen, das ist wirklich verdammt wenig für so ein System, was man
damit alles machen kann, also 13 Watt IDLE mit 10 Gehkarte, das meiste, das meiste IDLE
verbraucht tatsächlich die 10 Gigabit Karte, wenn ich die raus mache, braucht das irgendwie
7-8, das ist eine 12 Terabyte, ich glaube, so eine ist das, easy money,
ich glaube, so eine ist da drin, ja, oh guck mal, das geht mittlerweile hoch bis auf 16T,
was kosten 16T mittlerweile, ganz schön teuer, für was benutze die Platte, was ist denn da
alles drauf, lass mal überlegen, also nichts, was großartige Performance braucht, da ist
ein bisschen Nextcloud Zeug für Kontaktesync und Filesync und so drauf, da ist ein Wiki
drauf, da ist so ein Git Frontend drauf, da ist ein Samba Fileserver drauf, wo ich ab
und zu mal ein paar Sachen drauf backupe und das wird dann an eine USB Platte gespiegelt,
da sind 5-6 Sachen drauf, nichts davon, was großartige Leistung zieht, eine, eine Platte
ist da nur drin, also wie gesagt, ich hab da kein Raid, wie gesagt, ich bin von einem
fetten Raid 5, äh, nicht Raid 5, ein ZFS Raid 1 mit 13TB Platten bin ich jetzt zurück
auf so das billigste, was man sich irgendwie vorstellen kann, einfach, weil es einfacher
ist und das andere war total oversized overkill, das hab ich alles gar nicht gebraucht und
es war auch viel zu viel Singlepoint of Failure, wäre die alte 4HE Kiste verreckt, wie gesagt,
ich hätte noch nicht mal mein Rollo hochmachen können, also automatisch von Hand natürlich
trotzdem, deswegen hab ich das alles aufgesplittet, deswegen, wie gesagt, da war ja sogar Internetzugang
drauf, das hab ich jetzt alles aufgesplittet, Mikrotik Router macht Internet und ein bisschen
Firewall-Gedöns, die Fritzbox macht VoIP, weil VoIP will man nicht selbst machen, dann
macht die Kiste hier, die neben mir steht, ein bisschen Fileserver mit nachts einmal
Backup, da läuft noch ein Wiki drauf und es ist alles ein bisschen entzerrter gewesen,
geworden, dass man eine Sache kaputt geht, nicht so viel den Geist aufgibt.
Hast du nicht ein Nvidia Shield Fire TV, doch, ich hab sowohl ein Nvidia Shield als auch
ein Fire TV und ich hab sogar ein Nvidia Shield TV und wenn du was wirklich Gutes haben willst,
also wo du auch bereit bist, da mal ein bisschen mehr auszugeben und weniger Probleme zu haben,
dann ist das Shield TV wirklich meiner Meinung nach das Beste, was man sich kaufen kann.
Leider sieht das neue Shield TV kacke aus, ich mein, wie ist, also ok, das neue Pro sieht
so aus wie das alte, nicht Pro, ich mein, wie ist Nvidia auf die Idee gekommen, davon
zu dem da, the fuck, das werd ich nicht verstehen, ich weiß, das Pro ist das hier, aber früher
sah das normale, früher sah das normale so aus, guck mal, guck, das ist das normale
hier bei mir im Wohnzimmer, Halt's Maul, Klappe Max, komm mal hier, ich finde es normalerweise
blöd zu liken bevor ich das Video gesehen habe, aber bei Max kann man es machen, da
man einfach seit Jahren durchweg die gleiche Qualität hat, egal was gerade im Hype ist
oder sonst was, Max bleibt seiner Linie treu, exquisite, was laber ich, comment, so irgendwo
hier steht das Nvidia Shield TV rum, da sieht man sogar die Ente dabei, so, und dass ich
irgendwie Nvidia Schuhe hab, worum auch immer, so sah das früher aus und jetzt ist es bei
Nvidia, das normale Shield TV ist jetzt so ein komisches, so ein komisches Zäpfchen
oder was das ist und das Pro ist jetzt das, aber das finde ich wirklich gut, also das
hat sich gelohnt, das habe ich jetzt auch schon jahrelang, wie gesagt, das Video ist
von Mai 2017, da hatte ich das relativ neu, also sprich ich hab das jetzt dreieinhalb
Jahre und funktioniert wunderbar, butterweich, kostet vielleicht ein bisschen mehr als
die anderen Sachen, aber ich finde das lohnt sich, ja, die neue Fernbedienung ist auch
komisch mit dreieckig, bei mir ist die Fernbedienung noch flach, bei der alten Version, die ich
hab, denke den Controller muss man übrigens nicht dabei, weil den braucht man eigentlich
für quasi nichts, kannst du den Link von dem Video posten, ja kann ich machen, da zeige
ich noch ein bisschen mehr, also ich laber auch noch ein bisschen was, wie geil ich mein
Fernsehen finde, weil den hab ich gerade dort ausgepackt vor dem Video, also quasi vor dem
Video, so zwei Tage vorher oder so, da war ich noch ganz begeistert von, mittlerweile
muss ich sagen, ja geht immer noch, aber das Shield TV ist eindeutig das Highlight an der
ganzen Geschichte, was zeige ich denn da noch so, blöds in dem man nicht braucht, dass
es relativ viele Apps gibt, weil es Android TV ist, man sich Youtube angucken kann, dass
man in Kodi sich Filme angucken kann, man braucht, wie gesagt, man braucht dafür nicht wirklich
einen Shield TV, aber es gibt ja auch ein paar andere, also man kann sich ein Firestick
holen, das ruckelt zwar im Vergleich zu einem Shield TV ein bisschen, aber es ist jetzt
nicht so, dass es unbenutzbar wäre, ein bisschen Oldschool F-Zero Kram und dann mache ich noch,
am Ende zeige ich noch ein bisschen Remote Play vom PC, was mit dem Controller wirklich
erstaunlich gut funktioniert, Remote Play vom PC, ja Max liegt hier, hier guck mal,
da ist er, wohin irgendwo, Huge League, da guck mal da sitzt er, da sitzt er, jetzt ist
es raus Leute, jetzt ist es raus, so sieht er aus, liegt, was meinste warum ich die Kappe
auf hab an der Stelle, ich hab die Kappe aus einem einzigen Grund auf, falls ich mich doch
irgendwo zu sehr spiegele, dass man nix sieht, oder zumindest nicht so viel sieht, exquisite,
aber das Shield TV ist wirklich gut, da finde ich kann man nix falsch machen, soll ich mal
tun das aus, also taugt immer noch, Klatze Confirmed, ja Klatze Confirmed haben die Leute
schon immer erzählt, als ich noch ab und zu mit dem Kaboom-Essen-Videos aufgenommen hab,
da hieß es ja schon immer Max oder Kaboom-Klatze Confirmed, was witzig ist, weil zu dem damaligen
Zeitpunkt keiner von uns ne Klatze hatte, aber mittlerweile hab ich doch schon ne ganze Ecke
weniger Haare, ich bin noch ne ganze Weile von Klatze entfernt, aber es geht in die Richtung
ja, und der Kaboom hat mittlerweile ne Klatze, also lustigerweise wurde damals erzählt, Klatze
Confirmed, und keiner von uns hatte ne Klatze, aber jetzt ist es soweit, 5 Jahre später
ist es soweit, oder ne 8 Jahre, ach du Scheiß, das lange 8 Jahre später ist es soweit, Confirmed,
soll ich muss mir hier die ganzen Krempe, ups, oh Schafe, Wallpaper, erst mal aktualisieren
den Wallpaper, was ist das denn, Zeug, das ist übrigens das einzige wofür ich in meinem
Leben Bing verwende, für Image of the Day, ich verwende für nichts Bing, außer für
meinen Desktop Hintergrund, und auch nur weil das das erste Script war, also die erste Source,
also erste Quelle für so nen Daily Desktop Hintergrund, also ich ein bisschen was das
richtig cool wär, wenn ich irgendwie noch voten könnte, so dieser Hintergrund gefällt
mir und dann wird das AI lernen, welche Hintergründe mir gefallen, und würde dann immer mehr die
Hintergründe quasi auswählen, die für mich passen, das wär doch gut, aber das kann's
leider nicht, sammelt Bing weniger Daten als Google, ne wahrscheinlich nicht, ich glaube
die nehmen sich da alle nichts, egal ob es Google, Apple, Microsoft, Facebook, ok Facebook
ist nochmal härter, aber das nimmt sich alles nichts, tja und wie gesagt diese Boards,
deswegen hab ich das auch gesagt, diese Low Power Boards hat Intel jetzt letztens was
Neues vorgestellt vor ein paar Tagen, aber es gibt leider noch keine Board Ankündigungen,
das wird wahrscheinlich auch bis nächstes Jahr dauern, Hörwing sagt bei ihm hätten
die Hintergründe nur noch, ja dann passts ja zu dem was dir gefällt, ist doch gut, dann
hätte die AI ja quasi ihren Job richtig gemacht, Bing ist.NET Core, ist es? Ja gut warum nicht,
das ist ja auch ne Sache, die ich finde die Microsoft mittlerweile besser macht als früher,
also es gibt viele Sachen, also wirklich sehr viele Sachen die Microsoft besser macht wie
früher, äh jetzt besser macht als früher, aber ich hab den Eindruck, dass Microsoft
mittlerweile ihre eigenen Technologien auch mehr intern verwendet, und die logische Schlussfolgerung
daraus, dass sie den Windows Store und UWP selber nicht verwenden, die logische Schlussfolgerung
daraus ist für mich auch, das Zeug wird über kurz oder lang sterben, an den Windows Store
wirds wahrscheinlich noch weiter geben, aber gerade UWP ist kurz vorm, ja, also UWP ist
eigentlich mehr oder weniger tot, es gibt jetzt WinUI 3, was halt unter anderem auch
UWP kann, aber so wirklich nen Grund gibt es für UWP nicht mehr wenn das rauskommt.
So und wie gesagt am Wochenende, am Wochenende gucken wir uns die Geschichte an, und da probieren
wir auch ein bisschen mehr rum, äh das hier, am Wochenende probieren wir mal das hier aus,
ich weiß nicht ehrlich gesagt ob das Monkathos ist, aber ich mein es gibt es frei im Internet
zum Downloaden, also gar so Monkathos kann das nicht sein, wie gesagt da haben irgendwelche
Big Brain Leute das Betriebssystem von so nem Synology Ding extrahiert und bieten das
an zum selbst installieren, und das probieren wir am Wochenende mal aus, und da testen wir
auch ein bisschen mehr als heute bei Freenas, weil gut ich wusste jetzt ehrlich gesagt
noch nicht was ich da großartig noch ausprobieren soll, hier können wir beispielsweise auch
mal diese ganzen eingebauten Apps ausprobieren, die zum größten Teil, wie gesagt ich hab
kein Synology NAS, aber man kann es erstens online in der Demo ausprobieren und ich hab
auch schonmal vor Synology NAS Gesten gesessen, die Apps sind eigentlich ganz ok, ja gerade
die Kamera App ist ganz gut, also das Kameradashboard, ich hab vergessen wie es heißt, das ist ganz
gut und die Notes Apps und das ist eigentlich ganz gut gemacht, da müssen wir mal gucken
wie gut das funktioniert in dieser Version zum selbst installieren, Xpnology gibt es
schon ewig, ja ich weiß, zum ersten Mal hab ich das glaube ich vor 4 Jahren oder so gesehen,
aber ich hab es noch nie ausprobiert, das gucken wir uns mal am Wochenende an, kann
man die Synology Software nicht eh herunterladen, weiß ich nicht, ich dachte immer das haben
irgendwelche schlauen Leute extrahiert von irgendeinem Gerät, aber vielleicht kann man,
ach nee guck mal das ist ein Bootloader, dass man das offizielle Image auf nicht Synology
Geräten laden kann, ah yes, alles klar, ja dann stimmt das nicht was ich erzählt hab,
das ist irgendwas, aber es ist trotzdem Big Brain, Irving sagt bis jetzt hab ich nur mit
WPF gearbeitet, UVP, VINUI noch nie gesehen, ja VINUI ist ja auch, also bisher war VINUI
ja auch bloß so ein bisschen verbessertes UVP und hat versucht ein paar UVP Sachen rüber
zu bringen zu WPF zum Beispiel den Webview und für die Images, aber mit VINUI 3 wird
das komplett anders und das probieren wir, also wie gesagt wir haben es ausprobiert die
erste Preview Variante schon, die zweite müssen wir nicht ausprobieren, weil die ist genauso
kacke wie die erste, das hab ich schon abgeklärt, das hab ich mir schon angeguckt, aber das
hier werden wir ausprobieren und da hab ich wirklich große Hoffnung, dass Microsoft mal
wirklich was Gescheites hinkriegt, also zwei, ich bin auf zwei Sachen von Microsoft wirklich
gespannt was dort nettenmäßig angeht noch, einmal VINUI 3, das kommt jetzt übrigens
auch demnächst hier im November, hab ich das verschoben, sollte es sich eigentlich im Oktober
kommen, so und zumindest ist das seit 15 Jahren mal wieder das erste Mal, dass Microsoft versucht
ihre Desktop GUI Geschichte halbwegs sinnvoll zu gestalten, ja warum das Word Art ist, sei
immer dahingestellt, aber das Projekt an sich ist eine richtig gute Idee, weil Microsoft
hat das Problem und das ist so eine typische Microsoft Geschichte, die fangen immer Dinge
an und werfen sie zwischendurch wieder weg, guckt euch zum Beispiel Ribbonbars an, waren
da der letzte Scheiß, geilste Sache weg, so dann kamen sie auf die Idee wir machen irgendwelche,
wir machen den Desktop weg und kacheln, 3 Jahre später weg, dann kamen sie auf die Idee
wir machen Windows jetzt nur noch mit JavaScript Apps weg, dann kamen sie auf die Idee ja wir
machen Windows Sachen jetzt mit UWP, UWP hat auch gesagt, auch mehr oder weniger weg, es
gibt zig Sachen, Microsoft macht das einfach gerne und dementsprechend haben sie auch das
Problem, dass nix wirklich fertig ist, da muss man Apple ja wirklich immer zu gut halten,
was ihre Libraries und ihre Look and Feel Sachen angeht, da gucken die schon, dass das
immer auf dem aktuellen Stand ist und da haben die auch nicht 10 konkurrierende Sachen, weil
guck mal, unter Windows kannst du GUI anwenden und kannst du machen, als was es gibt, kilt
bei ms.com, das müssen wir uns angucken, weil kilt bei Google, das gucken wir uns gleich
an, weil unter Windows ist total, Silverlight war auch so ein Ding, was sie übelst gehypt
haben, das gucken wir uns gleich an, unter Windows hast du halt zig konkurrierende Technologien
und aus heutiger Sicht ist eigentlich ehrlich gesagt eins schlechter als das andere, Windows
Forms, das ist quasi so die Oldschool Variante, das ist die Windows API mit ein bisschen.NET,
ist hoffnungslos outdated, sieht man beispielsweise schon daran, dass das wichtigste Feature in
Windows Forms Anwendung nicht unterstützt wird, nämlich Emojis, also z.B. wenn man
jetzt ins Notepad geht und fügt Emojis an, dann geht es nicht, also Color Emojis reden
wir jetzt, geht nicht, also das wichtigste Feature geht schon mal nicht, also du hast
einmal Windows Forms, also sprich so die Oldschool GUI Technologie schlechthin, dann haben sie
irgendwann mal WPF gemacht, WPF ist zwar an sich ein bisschen neuer, unterstützt aber
die essentiellen neuen Sachen auch nicht, also sprich du kannst in WPF Apps, wenn man
jetzt mal auf diese Emoji Geschichte kommt, das geht da auch nicht und auch der eingebaute
Webview für Webinhalte ist in WPF einfach hoffnungslos veraltet und kacke und es sieht
auch nicht mehr richtig gut passend aus in den aktuellen Zeiten, außerdem ist WPF gerade
was das Rendern angeht immer noch in X9 und an vielen Stellen hapert es auch, Text sah
beispielsweise in WPF noch nie richtig gut aus, also anstatt das fertig zu machen macht
Microsoft immer neues Zeug, irgendwann kamen sie auf die Idee und haben gesagt wir machen
jetzt UWP, dann hat sich rausgestellt erstens der Windows Store ist kacke und Entwickler
die einfach Software veröffentlichen wollen, kostenlos für alle, haben kein Bock sich
ein 200-300 Euro Codesigning Zertifikat zu kaufen, dass sie ihre Anwendung verteilen
können, du hast ja aktuell nur die Auswahl Windows Store, dann kriegst du das Zertifikat
von Microsoft, aber niemand der noch irgendwie bei Verstand ist möchte seine Anwendung nur
über Windows Store verteilen oder du kannst die Anwendung so verteilen, also quasi einfach
per Download, dann brauchst du aber ein 200-300 Euro Codesigning Zertifikat, was sich auch
so keiner kaufen will, also UWP schonmal auch Müll, so und da kamen noch ein paar Zwischenstufen
aber eigentlich im Prinzip alles Müll und jetzt sind sie endlich auf die Idee gekommen
mit WinUI 3, ok wir machen es jetzt so, wir nehmen die UI Komponente von UWP, die UWP
UI-Geschichte ist ja quasi mehr oder weniger ein besseres WPF, ein bisschen moderneres
DIODX11 basiertes, weiß gar nicht ob es DIODX11 ist aber wahrscheinlich schon, basiertes
WPF, und die nehmen die UI Komponente und trennen die von UWP und bringen die quasi
einzeln raus, sodass du UWP, Windows Forms, WPF und quasi ohne UI, also ohne ältere Technologie,
dass du die UWP UI-Geschichte jetzt quasi auch in nicht-Store und nicht-UWP Apps verwenden
kannst, das ist die beste Idee UI-technisch, die Microsoft die letzten Jahre hatte, weil
an sich ist es meistens auch ganz gut was die basteln, aber in der Umsetzung, in dem
was danach kommt scheitern sie irgendwie immer, deswegen das ist eine gute Sache, da bin ich
echt gespannt drauf und wir gucken uns WinUI 3 die dritte Preview an, weil die erste war
Müll, die zweite ist immer noch Müll und warum ist die Müll ganz einfach, weil immer
noch keine Unpackaged-Native-Apps gehen, also sprich man kann immer noch nicht sagen, ok
ich mach einfach ne ganz normale Win32-Anwendung mit dem neuen GUI, das geht nicht, es geht
immer noch nur mit dieser Code-Signing-Geschichte, was halt auch Müll ist, so und das nächste
worauf ich wirklich gespannt bin, was Microsoft darauf macht, ist das da, ich sag ja schon
seit Jahren, dass.NET Core ein Cross-Plattform-UI-Framework braucht,.NET Core hat, also generell
die.NET Plattform hat riesen Sprünge gemacht seit Microsoft jetzt mit ihrer Open Source-Geschichte
angefangen hat, kann man nicht anders sagen, also.NET wird in so vielen Bereichen verwendet,
wo es früher nicht verwendet wurde und es ist viel, viel mehr Cross-Plattform geworden,
als man sich das früher erträumt hätte von Microsoft, also.NET, vor allem.NET Core
ist eindeutig die richtige Richtung, aber wie gesagt ich sage seit Jahren schon, ich
denke nicht, dass Microsoft da auf mich hört, ja ich sag's ja nur, weil das eine Sache
ist, die ich auch schon seit Jahren erzähle, dass es richtig geil wäre, es gäbe ein ordentliches
UI-Framework für.NET Core, weil realistisch betrachtet gibt es für Desktop-Cross-Plattform-Entwicklung
zwei Sachen, das ist einmal Electron, also sprich wir brauchen 500 MB RAM für einen Plaintext-Editor
oder Qt und das ist C++ mit eventuell ein bisschen JavaScript, also beides jetzt nicht
unbedingt die Dinge, wo ich so hyped drauf bin, also ich bin weder auf Electron-Apps
sonderlich hyped, als auch auf GUI-Anwendungen C++ programmieren sonderlich hyped, aber
das ist die einzig richtig sinnvolle zwei Sachen, die es gibt, was man auch daran sieht,
dass, ähm, guckt, keine Ahnung, guckt euch an, Visual Studio Code ist Electron, Origin
ist Qt mit Web-Engine, ähm, Battle.NET ist quasi auch mehr oder weniger, weniger Electron,
das ist nicht Electron, aber sowas ähnliches, ähm, also viele dieser Dinger sind einfach
auf in Ermangelung an Alternativen von Microsoft zu komische Dinger entstanden, wo man sich
denkt, ey, warum brauche ich für eine Windows-Only-Desktop-Anwendung, warum mache ich da, warum muss ich
da einen Browser laufen lassen, ja, aber gut, es gibt halt nichts Gescheites von Microsoft
als Alternative, so, und das, das fackeln sie jetzt mit WinUI ab, so, und das nächste
ist, wie gesagt, ich bin ja auch schon jahrelang der Meinung, es wäre nochmal ein richtiger
riesen Boost für die.NET-Plattform, wenn Microsoft mal ein eigenes Cross-Plattform-UI-Framework
rausbringt, weil auf dem Desktop haben wir da eigentlich nur Electron und Qt und jetzt
im Common, ähm, Dart, ähm, nicht Dart, äh, nein, Leute, Dart, Flutter, ähm, so, aber
Flutter ist auf dem Desktop jetzt noch nicht so extrem nice wie auf Mobile, ja, zum Beispiel,
du kannst da noch, es gibt, es gibt, das letzte Mal, wo ich mir das angeguckt habe, gab es
noch keinen richtigen Webview auf dem Desktop und es gab noch keine Möglichkeit, irgendwelche
3D, also irgendwelche OpenGL oder 3DX-Inhalte einzublenden, da sind sie dabei, sollte Flutter
das demnächst machen, ist Flutter auf jeden Fall auch eine gute Alternative zu Qt und
Electron und jetzt hätte Microsoft die Chance, Mobile, Mobile Cross-Plattform rede ich gar
nicht von, Mobile Cross-Plattform gibt es total viel, von React Native bis zu Flutter
bis zu, da gibt es tausende Sachen, aber gerade Desktop Cross-Plattform gibt es nicht so
wahnsinnig viel, da bleibt eigentlich nur Qt und Electron, so als realistische Sachen
aktuell, vielleicht Flutter in Zukunft, so, und sollte Microsoft jetzt wirklich ein echtes
Cross-Plattform GUI-Framework raushauen, was übrigens nicht mit.NET 5 kommt, sondern
erst mit.NET 6, das würde ein ultra riesen Boost geben für.NET, was denkst du bringt
die Umstellung von x68 Prozessoren zu ARM Prozessen bei Apple für die Entwickler, für
die Entwickler bringt das glaube ich nicht, macht das glaube ich keinen allzu großen
Unterschied, du kannst vielleicht einige Libraries nicht mehr verwenden, die es nicht für ARM
gibt, aber die wichtigsten Sachen wird es geben, ich glaube das wird nicht allzu großen
Unterschied machen, aber ich kenne mich auch im Apple Ökosystem nicht gut aus.
Ich glaube nicht, aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass es einen so großartigen Unterschied
machen wird.
Ja, und das hier ist der Versuch von Microsoft quasi ein.NET Cross-Plattform GUI-Framework
zu machen, allerdings, und da hört es auch schon wieder auf, das ist leider auf Basis
von ihrem olden Samorin-Forms-Gedöns, und da bin ich überhaupt kein Fan von, das gefällt
mir nicht, aber vielleicht kriegen sie das noch gescheit hin, vielleicht kommt da wirklich
was Gutes raus, also auf die zwei Sachen bin ich echt gespannt, was Microsoft die nächsten
Jahre macht.
So, aus Entwicklersicht, so, also, guck mal, KILT bei Microsoft, was haben, ok, da ist
noch nicht so viel drin, ich meine, KILT bei Google ist deutlich besser gefüllt, die Webseite
ist übrigens richtig gut, da kann man sich angucken, wann hat Google was rausgebracht
und wann wurde das abgesägt, und ich predicte ja mal, dass wir da in zwei Jahren auch Stadia
in der heutigen Form finden werden.
Mal abwarten, ob ich recht hab.
Der Gaming-Streaming-Hype ist ja schon komplett vorbei, aber die Meinung, dass man damit
Geld machen kann nicht, weil sonst würde nicht Amazon mit Game-Streaming jetzt anfangen.
Amazon fängt jetzt ja auch mit Amazon Luna an und macht Game-Streaming.
Ich weiß nicht, warum ausgerechnet die jetzt, ich meine, der Zug ist aus meiner Sicht schon
komplett abgefahren, Google ist mit Stadia, man muss ja sagen, Stadia war auch nicht das
erste, aber Stadia war so das erste mit Riesentammtamm drumherum, Google macht jetzt das und es
wird das Gaming revolutionieren und Gaming never seen before und es wird alles ändern,
im Prinzip hat Stadia nichts geändert, wenn man ehrlich ist.
Stadia hat einzig und allein gezeigt, dass es in manchen Regionen der Welt, wozu in Deutschland
mal ausgeklammert ist, ist ganz gut funktionieren kann.
Das ist aber auch das einzige, was Stadia gezeigt hat, dass die Leute keinen Bock auf
Stadia haben, sieht man z.B. an den Destiny 2 Zahlen, von allen Plattformen, wo es Destiny
2 gibt, also PC, PS4, Xbox und Stadia, spielen 0,5% der Spieler auf Stadia und das, obwohl
man eigentlich dafür ausgehen müsste, wenn etwas neu gelauncht wird auf einer Plattform,
dass dann dort die Leute zumindest erstmal, das ist wie wenn es eine neue Season gibt
in einem MMO, dass sie sich erstmal da drauf stürzen haben sie nicht, hast du Stadia selbst
getestet?
Noch nicht, ich hab mir die Stadia Founders Edition bestellt und ich hab das 2 Monate
vorher bestellt und dann haben die mir eine Woche vorher gesagt, ich bekomme es nicht
zu Release oder so und dann hab ich gesagt, wisst ihr was?
Und hab es wieder abgestellt, weil das sehe ich nicht ein, ich bezahle noch nicht eine
Founders Edition im Voraus sonst wann bestellt und dann sagen sie mir, ich krieg es nicht
geliefert.
So und dann hab ich wieder abgestellt, bin doch nicht bescheuert, das mein, Google verarscht
einen schon oft genug, aber gar so sehr verarschen, ich mein, was hat das gekostet, 150 Euro oder
so oder 170 Euro oder was auch immer.
Dissortion, das ist ein gutes Argument, er schreibt, das könnte sich bald ändern, Cyberpunk
2020 und mit der aktuellen Grafik klappen, das ist ein gutes Argument, ich glaube aber
trotzdem nicht, dass es die Stadia Beliebtheit pushen wird, wenn schon, also wenn gar nicht
dauerhaft.
Mag sein, dass sich ein paar Leute so ein Stadia Probe abholen, um das Cyberpunk zu
spielen, weil sie kein PC haben, der gut funktioniert, allerdings wird der Cyberpunk bestimmt auch
laufen mit einer Grafikkarte, die nicht unbedingt eine 3080 oder 3090 ist und davon sollten
die Leute eigentlich genug haben.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass es, es gibt vielleicht so einen kleinen Peak, aber insgesamt wird
es wahrscheinlich nicht allzu viel machen, das würde nur funktionieren, wenn Stadia
so ein richtig geiler revolutionärer Service wäre, dass die Leute quasi was brauchen,
das würde nur funktionieren, wenn Stadia so ein richtig geiler revolutionärer Service
wäre, wo die Leute quasi erstmal so den Einstieg brauchen, um zu erkennen, was für
ein geiler revolutionärer Service es ist, aber ist es ja nicht, deswegen, also es gibt
manche Sachen, da müssen erst ein paar Leute quasi die Genialität erkennen, dass es dann
auch immer mehr werden, aber bei Stadia ist es halt so, das hat am Anfang einen riesen
Hype, die Leute haben sich angeguckt und festgestellt, ja nee, braucht eigentlich kein Mensch.
Okay, System Requirements, okay, ist klar.
Okay, also irgendwelche uralt Grafikkarten gehen da nicht, also ich glaube, was ist denn
das Mindeste für deine, was ist denn das Mindeste, eine 9, nee, okay eine 7, 7, 8, okay, aha,
alles klar, ja, ich meine, das ist doch, also mal ehrlich, also jemand, der dann halbwegs,
okay, 12G RAM ist schon recht ordentlich, wieviel habe ich noch eins drin, 32, ne, RAM,
wo steht mein RAM, da, okay, ich habe genug RAM, aber mal ehrlich, jeder, der einen halbwegs
aktuellen PC hat, der sich ans Spielen richtet, hat doch sowas drinne, also die meisten sollten
das doch haben, ich meine, die meisten insgesamt natürlich nicht, wenn man sich ab und zu
mal diese Steam-Statistiken anguckt, dass die meisten Leute mit Intel-Onboard-Grafikkarte
rumkrebsen und sowas, dann ist klar, dann nicht, aber so die meisten, die ein bisschen
Spiele interessiert zum passenden Rechner haben, die sollten das doch eigentlich jetzt
auch schon haben und müssen da nicht zu Stadia gehen, ja, okay, Killpa Microsoft, was gibt
es da sonst was so, heute habt ihr gesehen, es ist 22 Uhr, ich muss gleich auf, also was
haben sie gekillt, Microsoft Silverlight, Moment, Silverlight wurde im, ich wusste gar nicht,
Silverlight ist noch supported, was, Silverlight ist seit 10 Jahren nicht mehr aktuell, Silverlight
juckt kein Mensch mehr, also wer sich noch dran erinnern kann, Silverlight war die Konkurrenz
zu Flash von Microsoft, 2007 und ein paar Jahre später hatte schon keiner mehr interessiert,
also seit 2010 ist das komplett irrelevant, ein bisschen so wie Flash dann auch irrelevanter
geworden ist und ich bin kein allzu riesen Apple-Fan, aber ich meine, ich hab selbst
ein paar Apple-Produkte, ja, aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich vom Apple Store übernachten
würde oder sowas, eins mag ich an Apple, ja, die ziehen ihre Sachen meistens durch und
gerade in Bezug auf Flash war das gut, also Apple, wahrscheinlich sogar Steve Jobs persönlich
hat entscheidend dazu beigetragen, dass wir uns nicht mehr diesen Mist von Flash geben
müssen, das war der richtige Anfang vom Ende, der richtige Anfang vom Ende von Flash war,
als Apple gesagt hat, auf dem iPhone gibt es kein Flash und der Android ging es ja noch
am Anfang und Flash war damals auch schon nicht beliebt, also mein Flash war damals
auch schon verhasst, ja, man hat sie irgendwie gebraucht, übrigens ich hab gelesen, wisst
ihr, das Farmville jetzt gleich wird geschlossen, weil Flash zu Port ausläuft, nicht dass mich
es persönlich betreffen würde, aber ich fand's nur witzig, das war mal so ein Game, was
Millionen gespielt haben zu einer Zeit, wo Facebook noch angesagt war, so was haben
sie sonst noch, Mixer, stimmt, Mixer, ich find's ja ein bisschen schade, dass Mixerdicht
ist, könnt ihr euch noch an den Age of Empires Stream erinnern, auf Mixer, wo sie aus versehen
ihre Vorbereitungen gestreamt haben und den Leuten erzählt haben, wie sie jubeln sollen,
wir sind zufällig mal auf Mixer auf den Age of Empires Stream gegangen und da haben die
ausversehen den Stream eingeschaltet und man hat im Hintergrund gehört, wie sie quasi
die Leute instruiert haben, wie geklatscht werden soll, wenn was vorgestellt wird, das
war schon ziemlich pains champ, aber ich find's trotzdem schade, dass Mixer weg ist, weil
Mixer war die einzige ernstzunehmende Streaming Konkurrenz, wo halt auch noch was mit richtig
Kohle dahinter steckt, ich mein, mal im Ernst, Facebook Gaming, Facebook Streaming, das gucken
sicherlich viele, weil Facebook ist halt so die Boomer-Plattform schlechthin, da gibt's
dann teilweise Leute, die haben Videos mit 600.000 Aufrufen, von denen hab ich noch nie
im Leben nichts gehört, aber die sind halt nur auf Facebook aktiv, aber ich seh Facebook
Gaming einfach nicht als die eSport-Gaming-sonstwas-Streaming-Gamestream-Plattform, genauso wenig wie YouTube Gaming,
auf YouTube Gucken auch viele Leute einfach dadurch, weil die ganzen Channels dann halt
auf YouTube mit 2.000.000 Abos oder so, man geht live, natürlich die Leute kriegen Notification
gucken, aber ich find Mixer war die einzige wirklich sinnvolle Alternative zu Twitch,
die hätte theoretisch mal was werden können, aber man hat's ja gesehen, auch mit Ninja
und Shroud ist das Ganze nix geworden, also außer für die beiden, für die beiden hat's
halt dicke Kohle, ich, Tribolon, ohne Mist, weil er's grad sagt, dem einzigen Laden, den
ich das zutrauen würde, irgendwie Twitch-Konkurrenz zu machen, auch was Gaming angeht und Livestreams,
ist TikTok, man kann TikTok hassen so sehr man will, was ist denn Trovololive, hab ich
noch nie, hab ich noch nie gehört, ich mach das nicht im Stream, okay das sieht aber auch,
das sieht auch billig aus, na komm, der, der beste, der, der größte Channel hat 160 Zuschauer
hier grad, ah nee, recommended, ich, ich zeig's nicht im Stream, weil ich mir nicht sicher
bin, ob ich zeigen darf, ob das, ob das so groß, ob das so groß ein, ach das ist das
von Tencent, genau, ob das so großartig einschlagen wird, ja die Chinesen streamen eh hauptsächlich,
Koreaner und Chinesen streamen eh öfters mal auf anderen Plattformen, da gibt's ja
noch mehr, da gab's noch, da gibt's noch, wie heißt das, ähm, Afrika oder so, gibt's
da noch in Korea, es gab mal Azubu, kannste ja noch, Alter, das war auch so ne Crap-Plattform,
Alter, ähm, ja, aber meiner persönlichen Meinung nach, ist das einzige, was irgendwie
Twitch in der Richtung Konkurrenz machen könnte, auch in Form von Popularität bei jungen Leuten
und sowas, ist so doof, es klingt TikTok, also sollte, sollte TikTok auf die Idee kommen
und äh, sagen, hey, wir machen jetzt in irgendeiner Art und Weise Game Streaming oder sowas,
das könnte echt was werden, könnte, also, könnte ich mir zumindest auch zusammen zu,
zu zusammenreimen, übrigens wusste dir das Reddit, Reddit hat auch nen Streaming-Feature,
das ist das, das verwirrendste Streaming-Feature aller Zeiten, ich verstehe es nämlich absolut
gar nicht, manchmal, wenn man auf Reddit ist, kriegt man eingeplendet, ich weiß gar nicht,
ob das jetzt hier drinnen ist, ne, jetzt, jetzt, hier ist irgendwie nicht, manchmal,
wenn man sich auf Reddit einloggt und, und nen Subreddit aufmacht, steht dann, steht
dann irgendwo hier dazwischen drinnen, äh, beliebte Übertragung und da, dann klickst
du da drauf und du kriegst nen Stream gezeigt, wo jemand ne Kamera hat, wie grad ein Ei aus
gebrütet wird, also, nicht dieses Ei, sondern halt ne Huhn, ne, und, das ist das verwirrendste
unsinnigste Streaming-Feature überhaupt, ich verstehe nicht, wozu es da ist, ist nur
im Start-Feed, ne, das ist auch auf anderen Subreddits, ich weiß, dass ich, ja, krieg
ich das nämlich, ich guck nämlich nie auf den Start, hier, Top-Broadcast, diese, ich
versteh das Feature nicht, ich mach jetzt nicht auf, da ist bestimmt Monka Tost dahinter,
ähm, ich versteh das Feature nicht, das ist einfach so random hier auf Reddit und, und,
und dann sieht man dann irgendwie, keine Ahnung, sowas, ne, ne, ne Straße und da gucken dann
7500 Leute zu, also, dieses Feature versteh ich nicht, ich hab ernsthaft kein Plastenschimmer,
wofür es da ist, so, die nächsten Channels haben dann auch kaum, haben dann auch kaum
Zuschauer, also, grade Reddit, die, die, die Streaming-Integration, die ist so versteckt
und so wir und, und, und so, so komplett, so, so, so komplett Anti-Reddit vom, vom Sinn
her, von einem Forum, das, das, also, das ist wirklich mit Abstand, also der Preis an
die randomste, äh, unsinnigste Streaming-Feature geht echt an Reddit, jetzt mal ernsthaft Leute,
wer von euch wusste überhaupt, dass Reddit einen Streaming-Feature hat?
Und wie war das jetzt neu? Das verf, versteh ich nicht. Oh, was haben sie sonst noch gekillt?
Mixer, Microsoft Reader, Windows Phone, ja gut, da ist es echt nicht Schaden drum. JustinTV,
klar, kenn ich JustinTV, Kappa, Kappa ist ja eigentlich JustinTV, also der Typ, der Typ,
also der, der Kappa-Typ, äh, war ja ein ehemaliger JustinTV, also jetzt Twitch-Stand, Mitarbeiter.
Ich bin alt, ja, ich bin huge alt. Ich mein, es verwirrt die Leute ja immer, wenn ich sage,
aber ich bin 36. Kann man sich das vorstellen? Da sitzt jetzt um 22 Uhr 11 ein 36-Jähriger
vor seinem PC und sagt in jedem zweiten Satz, Excellent Poggers und Pogu und Kekwe und spielt
so komische Sachen ein wie das hier. Eigentlich kaum zu glauben, oder? Aber das ist eine Sache,
ich muss übrigens gleich auf, aber das ist eine Sache, die ist wirklich besser geworden.
Also, man sollte, man muss sich immer sagen, früher war alles besser, war es nämlich nicht.
Eine Sache ist heute echt besser. Du kannst heute, oder vielleicht ist es mir einfach
nur auch egaler, es ist mir auf jeden Fall egaler wie früher, aber eine Sache ist heute
auf jeden Fall besser. Es ist heute deutlich mehr, wie soll man das nennen, sozial akzeptiert
als früher. Also sprich, so der Rahmen, in dem sich normal bewegt, ist deutlich breiter
als früher. Also, hätte man früher, wo ich noch ein bisschen jünger war, hätte ein 36-Jähriger
gesagt, ich sitze vor dem PC und mache Livestream, da kämen schon die ersten an, na du sollst
dich lieber um Frau und Kinder kümmern, oder irgendwie sowas bescheuertes. Also, die Range
von dem, was normal ist, ist deutlich breiter als früher und das finde ich gut. In allen
Bereichen. Heute ist es auch gar kein Problem mehr, wenn einer sagt, er ist schwul. Als
ich noch jünger war, und das ist noch gar nicht so lange her, wie gesagt, ich bin 36,
da wurdest du durchaus schepp angeguckt, wenn einer schwul war. Also, das ist alles noch
nicht so lange her. KappaPride. Also, das ist heute auch kein Ding. Klar, du hast immer
mal so ein paar verirrte Leute, die da Meinung sind, die musst du irgendwie gleich erhängen
oder so, gibt dir immer noch so ein paar Gestörte, aber im Großen und Ganzen ist das heute viel
mehr akzeptiert als früher. So viel mehr als normal akzeptiert als früher. Und das
finde ich gut. Cebaro, es gibt genug verrückte Leute. Ich weiß noch, auf YouTube war mal
irgendwie einer, der übelst den Friseur geflamet hat. Irgendeiner von den damals ein bisschen
größeren Channels. Das war auch so einer. Der einfach grundlos das gehasst hat, um es
zu hassen. Es ist nicht alles normal, aber es ist, ohne Mist, die Bandbreite von dem,
was als normal durchgeht heute, ist viel breiter als früher. Das finde ich eigentlich ganz
gut. Ich mache jetzt hier mal aus, weil, ach nee, ist die VM schon aus? Die Musik
ist auch schon aus. Das passt. Das will jetzt, dass ich ins Bett gehe. Ich muss morgen früh
wieder arbeiten. Tja. Hat er das mal gemacht, Cebaro? Das kenne ich nicht. Das gute Nachtlied.
Okay, Moment. Chat, weil ihr's seid. So Leute, macht's gut. Bis morgen, see you.